hey this is Andrew Brown your favorite
Cloud instructor over here on freako
Camp bringing you another free Cloud
certification and this time it's the
Microsoft Power Platform fundamentals
also known as the pl 900 and the purpose
of this course is to help you pass and
Achieve Microsoft certification so you
can go put that on your resume or your
LinkedIn so you can go get that job
promotion or get your first Cloud role
you've been looking for the way we're
going to achieve that is through lecture
content Hands-On labs and also a free
prax exam if you want to help support
more free Cloud certification courses
the best thing you can do is to purchase
the additional study materials but if
you don't have the money don't worry
because you can definitely pass using
the free content here so as always you
know I've taught a lot of courses here
Microsoft Azure Google terraform
kubernetes you name it I've taught it
for cloud over here so you are in good
hands and I will see you soon soon in
class ciao
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we're at the start of our journey
asking the most important question first
which is what is the Microsoft Power
Platform fundamentals
so the Microsoft Power Platform
fundamentals is an entry-level Microsoft
certification it has no prerequisites so
you don't need to have any prior
knowledge of the Power Platform
components or the cloud to learn this
specific course this course covers the
following key topics understanding the
business value of Power Platform and its
components such as power apps power bi
power automate and power virtual agents
identifying the capabilities and
limitations of each Power Platform
component understanding the dataverse
formerly common data service and how
data connectors and external Services
can be integrated creating basic canvas
and model driven power apps creating and
sharing power bi dashboards and reports
creating automated workflows using power
automate understanding the use cases of
power virtual agents and knowledge of
the basics of AI and the power platforms
AI Builder capabilities
so who is this certification for the
certification is designed for
individuals who are interested in
learning how to Leverage The Power
Platform to streamline business
processes automate tasks and create
custom Solutions you may consider this
certification if you are new to Power
Platform and want to learn the
fundamentals and benefits of Power
Platform in general you are a business
user administrator developer data
analyst or I.T professional you want to
understand the capabilities of power
platforms such as building basic
business processes using power automate
and power apps and gain skills and data
analysis with power bi and creating chat
Bots with power virtual agents or you
are a senior Power Platform
administrator or developer or in a
related role who needs to reset or
refresh their knowledge after working
for multiple years
so now let's take a look at the
Microsoft Power Platform certification
roadmap to see where we would go after
the Power Platform fundamentals and what
kind of roles would be associated with
those certifications
so at the start you get your Microsoft
Power Platform fundamentals which is at
the fundamental level after that we have
the associate level certifications such
as the Power Platform App Maker Power
Platform functional consultant and Power
Platform developer and we have an expert
level certification called The Power
Platform Solutions architect it's really
up to you to choose which field you're
interested in a common route could be
something like if you're a developer and
want to develop and secure Microsoft
Power Platform Solutions you could take
the Power Platform developer at the
associate level and then move on to
taking the Power Platform solution
architect at the expert level if your
interest lies more towards data analysis
you could take the power bi data analyst
to maximize the value of data assets
with Advanced analytics and eventually
take the Azure Enterprise data analyst
to build Enterprise scale data analytics
Solutions if you're an I.T professional
or citizen developer you could take the
Power Platform App Maker to simplify and
automate tasks and processes then take
the Power Platform functional console
resultant to extend and customize
Microsoft apps and services it's also
common for people to take multiple of
these associate level certifications it
doesn't have to be just one this is to
ensure they have a wide range of
knowledge on all of these areas for
possible career openings another route
you can take is the Dynamics 365
certifications which is a suite of
enterprise resource planning and
customer relationship management
applications it specializes in helping
businesses manage and streamline their
financials operations sales marketing
customer service and Human Resources
procedures also if you have an interest
in cloud computing you can explore
options such as the Azure administrator
and Azure developer from there you could
take the Azure Solutions architect or
devops engineer at the expert level so
as you can see there are many possible
paths to take and these are not all the
ones available on the list ultimately
it's up to you to decide what you want
to specialize in keep in mind that there
is no single perfect route these
suggestions are simply intended to
provide some guidance and help you make
your own choice voice
so how long is it going to take to pass
this certification well it's going to
really depend on your background but if
we had to generalize it we can look at
it as kind of a scale and so if you are
at the beginner level you're looking at
roughly 16 hours and when we say
beginner we're saying someone that has
never used Microsoft Power Platform
products like power apps power automate
power bi Etc someone that has never used
Microsoft Azure or any cloud provider or
someone that has no Tech background or
experience and when we're looking at the
other side of the Spectrum which is
someone that is experienced we're
looking at somebody who can watch this
at 1.5 to 2 times speed and are able to
absorb this information very quickly so
they have practical working experience
with the Power Platform products and is
familiar with using them they have
experience with Microsoft Azure or any
cloud provider like Amazon web services
or gcp so they can easily translate that
knowledge or they have a strong
background in technology where they've
worked in the industry for many years
and so you know their study time is
going to be a lot shorter at seven hours
or less and so on average most people
are going to take about 12 hours to
study for this course and when we talk
about the kind of stuff you'll be doing
it's going to be 50 lecture and labs and
we call them follow-alongs where the
idea is you follow along in your own
account and that other fifty percent is
the practice exams so if you look at the
length of the content which is around
three hours then you know you should
spend as much time doing practice exams
to pass and the recommended time to
study is about one to two hours a day
for roughly 10 days so what kind of
effort are we going to have to put in to
pass the exam well you have to watch the
lecture videos and memorize key
information you'll need to do Hands-On
labs and follow along with your own
account although as a fundamental
certification the certification is not
very heavy on Hands-On material but it
will provide a much greater
understanding of the topics you'll need
to know for the exam and you will need
paid online practice exams that simulate
the real exam and the last two here were
things that I used to never suggest
because you could literally just watch
the video shows and pass however
Microsoft has recently updated this exam
so it's a bit more difficult and so for
these last two points you do have to do
these two things for the paid online
practice exams that can be hard for some
people so I've made it easier for you by
providing you with a full free practice
exam on exampro.com
pl-900 and so you just have to sign up
with no credit card required and you'll
get a full set of questions that
simulate the real exam
so for the contents of the exam the
certification exam consists of six
domains each with its own weightage that
determines the number of questions from
that domain that will appear so for
domain one which is business value of
Microsoft Power Platform we're looking
at 20 to 25 percent for domain two
identify foundational components of
Microsoft Power Platform we should
expect 10 to 15 percent of the questions
from there for domain three the
capabilities of power bi were sitting at
around 10 to 15 percent of the questions
for domain four the capabilities of
power apps we have roughly 20 to 25
percent of the questions for domain five
capabilities of power automate it's
about 15 to 20 percent of the questions
and for domain six are the complementary
Microsoft Power Platform Solutions which
include power virtual agents and power
Pages it's about 15 to 20 percent of the
questions overall the exam is mostly
well balanced and evenly distributed
across all six domains so you won't be
faced with an excessive amount of
questions options from a particular
domain that may not be your strong suit
so where do you take the exam well you
can take the exam at an in-person test
center or online from the convenience of
your own home
Microsoft has partnered with the test
center Network Pearson VUE and it offers
in person or online and these exams are
proctored meaning there is somebody
watching you to ensure that you are not
cheating
in order to pass the exam you have to
score 700 points out of the thousand and
so 700 generally equates to 70 percent
but it's around 70 percent because
Microsoft uses scaled scoring this means
that they could adjust it based on how
many people are passing or failing so
always aim to get higher than 70 percent
the exam contains about 40 to 45
questions so you can afford to get
roughly 10 to 12 questions wrong there
is no penalty for wrong questions such
as minus one so you should always choose
an answer and the questions come in a
few formats multiple choice multiple
answer drag and drop and yes or no
questions
the duration of the exam is one hour or
60 minutes so you have a little more
than one minute per question the exam
time is 60 minutes but the seat time is
90 minutes see time refers to the amount
of time to review instructions show the
online Proctor your workspace read and
accept NDA and complete the exam and
provide feedback
and when you do pass the exam the exam
is valid forever Microsoft's fundamental
level exams do not expire and you do not
need to do a recertification so that
about covers the introduction of the
course
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going through an exam guide
breakdown of the Microsoft Power
Platform fundamental certification so
the first thing you want to do is to go
to this link here
learn.microsoft.com
us slash certifications slash exams
slash PL 900 and once you're here you
want to navigate to this link called
pl-900 study guide this will open an
organized study guide that Microsoft has
prepared for us for the Microsoft Power
Platform fundamentals exam we've already
covered a general overview on what the
exam is who the exam is for and a brief
overview on the topics but we'll need to
cover the exam breakdown in a bit more
detail this is the section we're looking
for skills measured which have been
updated recently as of making this
course so we already covered the six
main domains describe the business value
of Microsoft Power Platform identify
foundational components of Microsoft
Power Platform demonstrate the
capabilities of power bi demonstrate the
capabilities of powerapps demonstrate
the capabilities of power automate and
describe complementary Microsoft Power
Platform Solutions so I won't be going
through each point on the entire list
because it's quite long but I'll point
out the ones that I think you should
definitely pay attention to starting off
with the business value of Microsoft
Power Platform Services you'll
definitely need to know all of these
Services listed here and their value and
benefits
for the extending business solutions by
using Microsoft powered platform you'll
just need to know the general overview
of these services like Dynamics 365 and
Microsoft 365 apps but describing how
Microsoft Power Platform apps work
together would be the most important one
for the Power Platform Administration
and governance the most important one
here is would be the Power Platform
security model and environments for the
Microsoft dataverse it's an important
one to know things such as tables
columns and relationships in Microsoft
dataverse you will probably see business
logic and data flows in Microsoft
dataverse on the exam as well as the
components of a connector
for power bi the two important ones here
are power bi desktop and power bi
service and you'll need to know
dashboards workspaces reports and
paginated reports you'll also need to
know how to build a basic dashboard by
using power bi for power apps all the
sections here you'll need to know well
which are the differences between canvas
apps and model driven apps and their use
cases and capabilities for both you'll
also need to know how to build a basic
canvas and model driven app
for the power automate section the most
important ones would be cloud and
desktop flow and how power automate
cloudflows use connector triggers and
actions actions for power automate
desktop flows is another important one
and you'll need to know how to build a
basic power automate flow
for the complementary Microsoft Power
Platform Solutions you'll mostly just
need a general overview of power virtual
agents and the purpose of topics
entities and actions you'll also need to
know the use cases and capabilities of
power pages and AI Builder once again
there's a lot on the list so I couldn't
mention all the points so I highlighted
the ones I thought were the most
important but throughout the course
we'll definitely cover all of the
material in great detail
thank you foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and I'll be giving you a walkthrough of
our practice exam simulator so what
we're looking at here is a free practice
exam I provide for you all you have to
do is sign up on exam Pro and you can
redeem the free available content here
you don't need a credit card at all
these exam questions are up to date and
closely simulates what you'll see on the
exam you'll be getting a full set of 40
questions so it's a real simulation like
the actual exam so I'll be clicking in
here to start the exam and I'll show you
what it'll look like we won't be going
through the entire exam we'll only be
going through a couple of questions so
you can get an idea of how the exam
questions are structured and the level
of difficulty these questions are so the
first question we have presented with
here is you are working for a company
that uses Dynamics 365 sales to manage
their sales processes as part of
improving customer experience the
company wants to implement a chat bot on
their web page to interact with customer
questions they want to use Microsoft
Power Platform to extend the
capabilities of Dynamics 360 five sales
which application should you use to
create a chat bot and extend the
capabilities of Dynamics 365 sales so we
have four options to pick from and in
this scenario the best choice here
should be powered virtual agents so
we'll choose that
so the next question we have here is you
work for a busy eCommerce company that
has experienced significant growth in
Customer Support requests to enhance the
support experience for both customers
and support technicians the company
wants to implement a tool that enables
immediate notifications when new support
requests are submitted which tools
should you recommend to achieve this
goal in this scenario the answer should
be power automate
so you'll mostly be seeing multiple
choice and multiple select questions but
there'll also be a few true or false and
drag and drop questions in there as well
here's a multiple select question where
you have to select two choices to get
the right answer in this scenario the
first two options should be correct but
I don't want to spoil too much for you
let's end the exam here so you can see
how well you performed and to review the
questions
here we can see that we only answer two
questions correctly out of the 40.
all the practice exam questions provide
an explanation on why the answer was
correct and also an explanation for the
wrong answers
they'll also be links to the sources and
documentation so you can reference the
material
you won't need to perform any coding and
they won't ask you anything about code
in this exam
the length of the questions can vary
some questions are short and straight to
the point and in some questions you'll
be given a scenario and you'll have to
figure out which tool is best suited for
the requirement in these practice exams
I added a bit more context to it so that
you're over prepared so if you do really
well on these practice exams you should
do well on the actual exam
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be answering the most
important question what is Microsoft
Power Platform well Microsoft Power
Platform is a line of business
intelligence app development and app
connectivity software applications
Microsoft Power Platform is composed of
five key products power apps power
automate power bi Tower virtual agents
and power pages
we'll be going through a brief overview
of each product starting off with power
apps so powerapps provides a rapid low
code development environment for
building custom apps for business needs
it has Services connectors and a
scalable data service and app platform
to allow simple integration and
interaction with existing data some of
powerapps features include creation of
web and mobile applications easy user
experience developers can build custom
apps over 200 connectors to integrate
data and systems pre-built AI scenarios
and it provides private and secure
submission of information
power automate lets users create
automated workflows between applications
and services it helps automate
repetitive business processes such as
communication data Collections and
decision approvals power automate
features creation of Enterprise grade
process automation simple interface
allowing every level of user to automate
work tasks it has hundreds of pre-built
connectors it can utilize AI Builder and
it predicts outcomes to improve
performance
power bi which stands for business
intelligence is a business analytics
service that delivers insights for
analyzing data it can share insights via
data visualizations which make up
reports and dashboards to enable fast
informed decisions some of power bi
features include scales across an
organization and has built-in governance
and security display data in the most
user-friendly way possible detailed and
attractive visualizations access vast
volumes of data from multiple sources
gather analyze publish and share Excel
business data and it can perform
real-time stream Analytics
power virtual agents enables anyone to
create powerful chat Bots using a guided
no code graphical interface without the
need for data scientists or developers
it minimizes the it effort required to
deploy and maintain a custom Solution by
empowering subject matter experts to
build and maintain their own
conversational Solutions
sum of power virtual agents features
include chat Bots to perform in action
by simply calling a power automate flow
flows help users automate activities or
call back-end systems reduce costs by
easily automating common inquiries
utilize existing flows that have been
created in their power apps environment
and improve customer satisfaction
power pages is the latest addition to
Microsoft Power Platform that allows
users to build and publish web pages
without the need for extensive coding
knowledge with power Pages users can
create customized web pages using a drag
and drop interface in a variety of
pre-built templates blocks and
components
these Pages can be connected to a data
source such as dataverse to display and
edit data power pages also offers
Advanced features such as embedding
power bi dashboards and adding custom
code users can publish their Pages as a
standalone website or embed them within
existing applications additionally power
Pages provides analytics to help users
understand page usage and engagement
so that's a brief summary of the five
main products of Power Platform we'll be
going through these products in Greater
detail later down in the course
foreign
the next topic we'll be covering are the
key Power Platform features Microsoft
Power Platform has several cross-cutting
features that can be utilized to
maximize its potential including AI
Builder Microsoft dataverse and
connectors AI Builder lets users and
developers add AI capabilities to the
workflows and power apps they create in
use
it is a solution that makes it simple to
integrate intelligence into your apps
and workflows to predict outcomes and
enhance business performance without
writing code
Microsoft dataverse is a scalable data
service and app platform which lets
users securely store and manage data
from multiple sources and integrate that
data in business applications using a
common data model to ensure ease and
consistency to users
this platform is the foundation for
consolidating displaying and
manipulating data allowing the
components of Microsoft Power Platform
to work together efficiently connectors
enable you to connect apps data and
devices in the cloud they act as a
bridge facilitating the movement of
information and commands across systems
there are more than 600 connectors for
Microsoft Power Platform enabling all
your data and actions to connect
cohesively some of the popular
connectors include Salesforce Office 365
Twitter Dropbox and various Google
services so these are just a few of the
features available in the Power Platform
that can be leveraged to realize its
full potential
foreign
[Music]
organizations face challenges in
creating solutions that assist their
users and modernize their systems these
difficulties arise from a lack of
resources needed to meet the continually
evolving demands of modern businesses
factors that are having an impact on
businesses include the changing
Workforce expectations The increased
costs of custom application development
the need to become more agile and the
requirement to scale development
efficiently organizations must adapt to
the way people work and provide more
collaborative digital experiences to
empower the upcoming Workforce
custom application development is time
consuming and expensive and
organizations must develop Solutions
quickly based on fast-changing business
demands
to meet these needs organizations must
change how they develop Solutions and
create hybrid development teams that
include citizen developers to empower
the entire organization to grow
the Power Platform makes it easy for
organizations to address all the
challenges mentioned
the business value of Microsoft Power
Platform lies in its ability to empower
organizations to build custom solutions
that automate processes increase
productivity and drive business outcomes
by enabling non-technical users to build
apps workflows and chat Bots without the
need for extensive coding expertise
Power Platform lowers the barrier to
entry for digital transformation
initiatives
this empowers organizations to rapidly
create and deploy solutions that address
their unique business challenges leading
to increased agility streamlined
operations and improve customer
experiences
Additionally the platform's ability to
integrate with existing systems and
services means that organizations can
leverage their current Investments while
unlocking new capabilities and insights
Power Platform helps reduce total costs
of ownership minimize internal
development and support as well as
third-party license costs while
improving compliance and security and
expanding the pool of available
development Talent
Power Platform helps increase
performance and efficiency increase
business process Innovation with
applications that improve performance
operational efficiencies and reduce
costs while managing risks effectively
and Power Platform helps provide faster
time to Value provide increased business
agility with much faster responses to
situations and deliver business
innovation in a reduced time scale
in summary Power Platform helps
organizations achieve their digital
transformation goals faster more cost
effectively and with greater flexibility
and scalability than traditional
development approaches ultimately adding
significant business value
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
how Microsoft Power Platform apps work
together with Microsoft Dynamics 365
apps
Microsoft Power Platform in Microsoft
Dynamics 365 are two different platforms
but they can work together seamlessly to
provide powerful Business Solutions
powerapps allows users to create custom
business applications with little or no
code these custom apps can be used to
perform various tasks such as managing
data automating workflows and analyzing
data power apps can also integrate with
Dynamics 365 apps to enhance their
capabilities
Dynamics 365 apps are designed for
specific business functions such as
sales marketing customer service and
finance these apps are built on the
common data model which provides a
standard and consistent way to organize
and store data across different
applications
power apps can use the common data model
as a data source allowing them to
connect and integrate with Dynamics 365
apps this means that data can flow
seamlessly between power apps and
Dynamics 365 apps and users can work
with the same data across both platforms
power apps can also leverage the
advanced functionality of Dynamics 365
apps such as customer relationship
management or enterprise resource
planning capabilities
in summary Power Platform apps and
Dynamics 365 apps can work together to
provide a unified and comprehensive
solution for businesses power apps can
be used to extend the functionality of
Dynamics 365 apps or create custom apps
that integrate with Dynamics 365 data
this integration between the two
platforms provides a powerful solution
for managing and analyzing business data
[Music]
Microsoft Power Platform Solutions work
together with Microsoft 365 apps and
services to create a unified approach to
digital transformation with the
integration of powerapps power automate
power bi and dataverse businesses can
create customized solutions that
automate processes visualize data and
gain insights to drive informed
decisions for example a company may use
power apps to create a custom form that
captures customer information and then
use power automate to automatically send
that information to Microsoft Dynamics
365 for sales they can also use power bi
to create reports that show customer
Trends and behavior and use that
information to make strategic decisions
the integration with Microsoft 365
allows businesses to leverage existing
data sources and systems to build apps
and automate workflows power apps and
power automate can interact with
Microsoft teams SharePoint Outlook and
other Microsoft 365 apps enabling users
to easily access data and Trigger
workflows directly from their familiar
interfaces
additionally power bi allows businesses
to visualize data from Microsoft 365
apps such as Excel SharePoint and
Dynamics 365 alongside data from other
sources
this provides a comprehensive view of
business operations and allows for
better decision making
overall the integration of Microsoft
Power Platform with Microsoft 365 apps
and services allows businesses to
streamline their processes increase
productivity and gain valuable insights
to drive their digital transformation
Journey forward
foreign
we've briefly gone over the main Power
Platform products and their key features
but we haven't really touched on how
Power Platform apps can work together
so the integration of Microsoft Power
Platform apps is achieved through the
utilization of a common data model which
is a standardized and modular collection
of data scheme is designed to work
seamlessly together by leveraging this
model various Power Platform apps such
as power apps power automate and power
bi can effectively collaborate and share
data for example a power app can use
data stored in Microsoft dataverse and
power automate can automate tasks Based
on data in a power app power bi can then
visualize the data from both the
PowerApp and power automate to provide
insights for informed decision making
the various Power Platform apps also
offer connectors that allow for
integration with other services such as
Microsoft 365 apps and third-party
applications by leveraging these
connectors users can create end-to-end
solutions that automate complex business
processes and improve overall efficiency
Microsoft Power Platform has multiple
apps that collaborate to offer a
complete solution for users to design
and handle personalized apps automate
processes and analyze data power apps
allows users to create custom
applications with a drag and drop
interface these apps can then be
integrated with other Microsoft services
and external data sources power automate
enables users to automate repetitive
tasks and workflows between various apps
and services this can include automating
notifications data collection approvals
and much more
power bi is a data visualization tool
that allows users to create reports and
dashboards to analyze data from multiple
sources the data can come from various
sources like spreadsheets databases or
cloud-based Services Microsoft dataverse
provides a centralized location for data
storage and management allowing users to
create and manage data entities and
relationships between them all these
apps work together seamlessly allowing
users to create a customized solution
that can automate their business
processes manage data effectively and
derive valuable insights through data
analysis
foreign
the next topic we'll be covering is how
Microsoft Power Platform works with
Microsoft teams
Microsoft Power Platform Works
seamlessly with Microsoft teams a
collaboration platform for teams to
communicate and work together with Power
Platform integrated into teams users can
access and use powerapps power bi and
power automate without leaving the
team's interface
for example users can create and share
power apps directly Within A team's
Channel or chat allowing team members to
collaborate and access the app in real
time
similarly users can access and view
power bi reports and dashboards Within A
team's Channel or chat making it easier
to share Data Insights and collaborate
on analysis
power automate can be used to create
automated workflows within teams
enabling users to trigger actions and
send notifications in response to
specific events for example a power
automate flow can be created to notify A
team's Channel when a new item is added
to a SharePoint list or trigger a
message in teams when a specific action
is taken in a power app
power virtual agents is a chatbot
development platform within Microsoft
Power Platform that can be integrated
with Microsoft teams
with this integration businesses can
build and deploy chat Bots and teams to
provide 24 7 support answer frequently
asked questions and automate simple
tasks overall the integration of
Microsoft Power Platform with Microsoft
teams provides users with a seamless and
streamlined experience for collaboration
and productivity
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be discussing
is how Microsoft Power Platform Business
Solutions can consume Microsoft Azure
services
Microsoft Power Platform Business
Solutions can consume Microsoft Azure
Services through their integration with
Azure apis and connectors Azure provides
a wide range of cloud services that can
be leveraged by Power Platform apps such
as Azure functions Azure cognitive
services and Azure machine learning one
way is through the use of azure
connectors which enable Power Platform
apps to access and manipulate data
stored in Azure services such as Azure
blob storage Azure SQL database and
Azure event hubs this allows businesses
to Leverage The Power of azure services
within their Power Platform Solutions
another way Power Platform can consume
Azure Services is through the use of
azure functions which can be triggered
by power automate flows this enables
businesses to create custom logic and
Integrations that run on demand are
based on specific events such as the
creation of a new record in Dynamics 365
or the receipt of an email in Outlook
power bi can also be used to consume
Azure Services by connecting to data
stored in Azure services such as Azure
data like storage and visualizing that
data through dashboards and reports this
allows businesses to gain valuable
insights from their Azure data in a
user-friendly and easily digestible
format
power apps can consume Azure cognitive
Services which includes Ai and machine
learning capabilities like natural
language processing speech recognition
and computer vision to add intelligent
features to custom applications
overall the ability to consume Azure
services within Power Platform Solutions
provides businesses with additional
capabilities and flexibility to build
powerful customized solutions that meet
their unique needs
[Music]
the Microsoft Power Platform security
model is designed to ensure that data
and resources within Power Platform
applications are protected from
unauthorized access or modification
the security model of Power Platform is
based on user roles permissions and data
governance policies and consists of
three layers tenant level environment
level and data level security
at the tenant level security is managed
by the Microsoft 365 admin Center which
allows administrators to manage user
accounts access to services and other
settings that impact the entire tenant
at the environment level security is
managed through the Power Platform admin
Center which allows administrators to
create and manage environments and
control access to data and applications
within those environments
data level security is implemented using
role-based access control and Azure
active directory to manage permissions
and access to data within the platform
this means that administrators can
control access to data in actions within
the Power Platform using authentication
with organizational credentials ensuring
that users only have access to
authorized resources and data the
platform also includes audit logging and
Reporting capabilities which allow
administrators to monitor user activity
and identify potential security risks
Power Platform has several built-in
security features such as conditional
access policies multi-factor
authentication and data loss prevention
policies that can be configured to meet
specific security and compliance
requirements
data governance policies can also be
implemented within Power Platform to
ensure that data is protected and
compliant with regulatory requirements
for example data loss prevention
policies can be set up to prevent users
from sharing sensitive information
outside of the organization and
conditional access policies which
control access to data based on factors
such as device type and location
data protection is insured through
encryption of data both in transit and
at rest Power Platform services use
industry standard encryption protocols
to ensure data privacy and protection
Additionally the platform is designed to
comply with various Regulatory and
Industry standards including gdpr HIPAA
and ISO 27001 to ensure that
organizations can use the platform to
store and manage data in a secure and
compliant manner overall the Power
Platform security model is designed to
ensure the protection and privacy of
data while providing flexibility and
ease of use to users
foreign
[Music]
platform an environment is a designated
space to manage and store an
organization's business data apps chat
Bots and flows it can be used as a
container to separate apps with
different roles security requirements or
Target audiences how environments are
utilized will depend on the
organization's needs and the apps being
built for example you can build your
apps or chat bots in a single
environment you can group the test in
production versions of your apps or chat
bots in separate environments you can
create environments for specific teams
or departments in your company with
relevant data and apps for each audience
or you might also create separate
environments for different Global
branches of your company
in Power Platform each environment is
associated with an Azure active
directory tenant and is bound to a
specific geographic location any
resources created in an environment such
as apps chat Bots connections and flows
are also bound to that location each
environment can have only one dataverse
database which provides storage for your
apps and chat Bots
the apps you create in an environment
can only connect to the data sources in
that same environment including
connections gateways flows and dataverse
databases this means that an app created
in what environment cannot connect to
the data sources in another environment
for example consider a scenario where
you've created two environments named
test and Dev and created a dataverse
database in each of the environments
if you create an app in the test
environment it will only be permitted to
connect to the test database it won't be
able to connect to the dev database
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering are
environment permissions and Power
Platform so there are two pre-built
roles and environments that Grant
permissions environment admin and
environment maker the environment admin
role can perform all administrative
actions on an environment such as adding
or removing a user or group from either
the environment admin or environment
maker role provisioning a dataverse
database for the environment View and
manage all resources created within the
environment and set data loss prevention
policies after creating the database in
the environment you can use the system
administrator role instead of the
environment admin role the environment
maker role can create resources such as
apps connections custom connectors
gateways and flows using power automate
within an environment environment makers
can share the apps they create with
other users or groups within the
organization however users or groups
with these roles are not automatically
granted access to the environment's
database if one exists access to the
database must be granted separately
there are five main types of
environments in Power Platform wide in
production this is the default
environment and it's where you deploy
your finished apps and solutions that
are ready for use by end users
two sandbox this is a non-production
environment that you can use to develop
and test your apps and solutions without
affecting the data in your production
environment
three trial this is a temporary
environment that you can use to evaluate
Power Platform before purchasing a
license the trial environment is valid
for 30 days
for developer this is a non-production
environment that is designed for
developers to build and test their
Solutions it provides full access to All
Power Platform features and capabilities
and five default this environment is
automatically created for each tenant
when it is provisioned it cannot be
deleted but it can be renamed and its
settings can be customized to meet your
organization's needs
thank you
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
the Microsoft Power Platform admin
Center and where to perform specific
administrative tasks
the Microsoft Power Platform admin
Center is a web-based portal that allows
administrators to manage and monitor
their Power Platform environments
including powerapps power automate power
bi and dataverse you should always check
for administration settings as your
first step when looking to administer
Microsoft dataverse
settings are grouped into the following
broad categories and are accessible by
selecting the link on the left hand side
of the portal starting with environments
this section lists all instances of
Microsoft dataverse data policies this
section lets you set up policies to
restrict which data connectors can be
used with Microsoft dataverse to limit
what data can flow into or out of
Microsoft data versus tables and data
integration this section lets you create
or add predefined connections and
monitor these connections between
Microsoft dataverse and other data
stores like Salesforce or SQL Server
in the admin Center administrators can
perform various administrative tasks
such as manage environments create
delete or manage environments and view
environment details and settings manage
security manage permissions for
environment roles and data loss
prevention policies
manage data manage dataverse databases
configure data policies and view data
Integrations manage analytics view usage
metrics monitor data flows and configure
Telemetry settings manage connectors
configure and manage connectors and view
connector usage and Analytics
manage gateways configure and manage
gateways and view Gateway usage and
Analytics
manage custom connectors create manage
and deploy custom connectors
manage flows manage and view all flows
in the environment
age apps manage and view all apps in the
environment
and manage AI Builder manage and
configure AI Builder models and data
administrators can access the Power
Platform admin Center by signing into
admin.power
platform.microsoft.com with their
Microsoft 365 or Power Platform
credentials
thank you
the Microsoft 365 admin Center is a
web-based portal that allows
administrators to manage and monitor
their Microsoft 365 tenant including
users groups licenses settings and
security here are some examples of
specific administrative tasks that can
be performed in the Microsoft 365 admin
Center why do user management admins can
add delete and modify user accounts
reset passwords and manage user roles
and permissions 2. group management
admins can create and manage groups
assign group owners and control group
settings three license management admins
can purchase assign and manage licenses
for Microsoft 365 apps and services
for Security Management admins can set
up and manage security features such as
multi-factor authentication conditional
access and device management live
settings management admins can customize
various settings such as email settings
SharePoint settings and team settings to
meet the needs of their organization six
compliance management admins can manage
compliance features such as data loss
prevention retention policies and
e-discovery seven billing and
subscriptions admins can manage billing
information and payment methods view
usage reports and purchase new
subscriptions
to access the Microsoft 365 admin Center
go to admin.microsoft.com in your web
browser enter your work or school
account credentials and then you will be
taken to the dashboard where you can
perform various administrative tasks
overall the Microsoft 365 admin Center
provides a central location for
administrators to manage and configure
various Microsoft 365 services for their
organization
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going through an overview
of the dataverse Microsoft dataverse
formerly known as common data service is
a cloud-based solution that easily
structures various types of data and
business logic to support interconnected
applications and processes in a secure
and compliant manner it is a part of the
Power Platform Suite of tools provided
by Microsoft and is tightly integrated
with other Power Platform products such
as powerapps power automate and power bi
dataverse allows users to store and
manage data in a secure and scalable way
with a flexible data model that can be
customized to meet specific business
needs it provides a set of tools for
creating configuring and managing data
entities fields and relationships and
allows users to Define complex business
logic using no code low code approaches
such as formulas and workflows dataverse
supports data integration with a wide
range of external data sources including
other cloud-based applications
on-premises databases and various
third-party services
it also provides Advanced features such
as data validation auditing and Version
Control and can be used to build a
variety of business applications such as
CRM HR management and financial
reporting among others
here is an image that describes what's
in the box of Microsoft dataverse
breaking it down into categories such as
security logic data storage integration
and so on
security dataverse handles
authentication with Azure active
directory to allow for conditional
access and multi-factor authentication
it supports authorization down to the
row and column level and provides Rich
auditing capabilities
logic dataverse allows you to easily
apply business logic at the data level
regardless of how a user is interacting
with the data the same rules apply these
rules could be related to duplicate
detection business rules workflows or
more
data dataverse offers you the control to
shape your data allowing you to discover
model validate and report on your data
this control ensures your data looks the
way you want regardless of how it is
used
storage dataverse stores your physical
data in the Azure Cloud this cloud-based
storage removes the burden of worrying
about where your data lives or how it
scales these concerns are all handled
for you
integration dataverse connects in
different ways to support your business
needs apis webhooks Eventing and data
exports give you flexibility to get data
in and out
a dataverse database is a single
instance of Microsoft dataverse which
stores data in a set of standard and
custom data structures called tables a
table is a logical set of rows that is
used to store data rows within a table
contain many columns to manage
individual pieces of information about a
single row
you can create one or many database
instances in Microsoft dataverse to host
data behind your business solutions each
instance of a Microsoft dataverse will
start with the same set of tables to
store data but you can always extend and
customize the Microsoft dataverse
database to meet specific business needs
scalability a dataverse database
supports large data sets and complex
data models tables can hold millions of
items and you can extend the storage in
each instance of a Microsoft dataverse
database to four terabytes per instance
the amount of data that is available in
your instance of Microsoft dataverse is
based upon the number and type of
licenses that are associated with it
data storage is pulled between all
license users so you can allocate
storage as needed for each solution that
you build overall Microsoft data versus
a powerful and flexible platform for
managing and processing data with a wide
range of applications across different
Industries and business domains
[Music]
so a common question asked is what is
the difference between traditional
databases versus Microsoft dataverse
well traditional databases and Microsoft
dataverse have several differences in
terms of their architecture
functionality and usage here are some
key differences while the architecture
traditional databases are typically
relational databases that store data in
tables with defined relationships
between them dataverse on the other hand
is a note code low code platform that
uses a data model to store data in an
entity attribute value format to
scalability traditional databases can be
scaled up or down based on demand but
this usually requires a dedicated team
of database administrators to manage the
hardware and software and contrast
dataverse is a cloud-based platform that
automatically scales to meet changing
demands without requiring any manual
intervention
three integration traditional databases
require custom integration code to
connect with other systems whereas
dataverse integrates seamlessly with
other Microsoft products and services
such as power apps power automate and
Dynamics 365.
for customization traditional databases
can be customized using SQL queries and
programming languages such as Java or
python while dataverse provides a
graphical interface that allows users to
create custom entities fields and
relationships without writing any code
five security traditional databases
typically require extensive
configuration to secure data at various
levels such as at the network server and
database levels in contrast dataverse
has built-in security features that
provide granular Access Control to data
at the entity and field levels in
summary while traditional databases are
suitable for large-scale
mission-critical applications that
require extensive customization and
management data versus design for no
code low code applications that require
quick and easy development integration
and management of data
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering tables and columns
and dataverse a table is a logical
structure containing rows and columns
that represents a set of data here is a
screenshot of the standard contact table
in various types of columns it includes
types of tables the three types of
tables are standard tables also known as
out of the box tables come pre-installed
in a dataverse environment these include
tables such as account business unit
contact task and user most of these
standard tables can be customized to
suit specific needs additionally tables
that are part of a managed solution and
marked as customizable will also appear
as standard tables users with the
necessary permissions can modify these
tables if the customizable property is
set to True manage tables are those that
cannot be customized and are imported
into the environment as part of a
managed solution
custom tables meanwhile our managed
tables that are either imported from an
unmanaged solution or are created
directly within the dataverse
environment these tables can be fully
customized by users with the appropriate
privileges
columns serve as a means of storing a
specific piece of information within a
table row much like an Excel column
columns have data types meaning that you
can store data of a certain type in a
column that matches that data type
for example dates are stored in columns
with the date data type while numbers
are stored in columns with the number
data type
the number of columns in a table can
vary significantly ranging from a few to
several hundred however having too many
columns could indicate a need to
reevaluate how data storage is
structured for the solution
in Microsoft dataverse a standard set of
tables is provided by default and each
of these tables has a predetermined set
of columns
[Music]
the next topic will be covering are
relationships and dataverse in Microsoft
dataverse relationships Define the way
that different tables in the system are
connected or linked together based on
shared data a relationship specifies how
data in one table is related to data in
another table
relationships are defined by creating a
field in the primary table that is used
to store a reference to the related
table this field is called a foreign key
and it contains a value that matches the
primary key of a record in the related
table when data is entered or updated in
the system the relationships ensure that
related data is updated consistently
across the tables which helps to
maintain the Integrity of the data
within the system relationships are an
essential aspect of building complex
data models and dataverse that can
support a variety of business scenarios
they allow users to connect and organize
data in meaningful ways which can help
to improve efficiency accuracy and
insight into business operations
there are three types of relationships
in dataverse why one to many this is the
most common relationship type in which
one record in the primary table is
associated with many records in the
related table for example a customer
could have multiple orders in the system
to many to one in this relationship type
many records in the primary table are
associated with a single record in the
related table for example many orders
could be associated with a single
customer
three many to many this relationship
type involves many records in both the
primary and related tables being
associated with many records in the
other table for example a customer could
have multiple orders and an order could
involve multiple products
foreign
moving on to the next component of the
data Versa environments environments are
used to store manage and share your
organization's business data apps and
flows in Microsoft Power Platform for
each environment created one Microsoft
dataverse databases provisioned for use
solely within that environment these
environments also provide the ability to
manage user access security settings and
Associated Storage for the database and
environment is created within a specific
Microsoft Azure active directory tenant
and its resources can only be accessed
by users within that tenant in addition
each environment is bound to a
geographic location such as the United
States upon creating a Microsoft
dataverse database within an environment
the database is created within the data
centers located in the environment's
geographic location
furthermore any items generated within
the environment including connections
gateways power automate workflows and
others are also bound to the
environment's location
by establishing multiple environments
you can efficiently manage solution
development and data storage for
instance you may set up distinct
environments for development testing and
production use additionally environments
can be created based on specific
Geographic locations
for example an environment for Europe
and another for Asia may be established
each of these environments is associated
with zero or only one instance of
Microsoft dataverse
foreign
the next topic we'll be covering are
business rules Microsoft dataverse
provides a feature to Define business
rules which allow you to apply and
maintain business logic at the data
layer rather than the app layer this
means that the business rules you create
in dataverse are effective regardless of
where you interact with the data
business rules provide a powerful way to
enforce rules validate data or set
values regardless of the form used for
data input they can increase data
accuracy simplify application
development and streamline forms for
users
both canvas and model driven apps can
use business rules with actions such as
set column values clear column values
validate data and show error messages
model driven apps can also use business
rules to show or hide columns enable or
disable Collins create business
recommendations based on business
intelligence
here is an example of a simple yet
powerful use of business rules the rule
is set up to make the credit limit VP
approver field mandatory when the credit
limit exceeds one million dollars
conversely the field is optional when
the credit limit is below one million
dollars by applying this business rule
at the data level instead of the app
level you have better control of your
data this can ensure your business logic
is followed whether it is being accessed
directly from powerapps Power automate
or via an API the rule is tied to the
data not the app
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering are
data flows and dataverse
data flows in Microsoft dataverse are a
way to extract transform and load data
from various sources into dataverse
tables with data flows you can automate
the process of importing data from
different sources and transform it into
a consistent format this allows you to
streamline the data integration process
reduce data entry errors and improve
data accuracy data flows are created
using power query which is a data
transformation in cleansing engine that
enables you to transform data from a
variety of sources such as Excel
SharePoint SQL server and many others
you can use power query to perform
operations such as filtering sorting
grouping and aggregating data and then
load the transform data into dataverse
tables
data flows also support incremental
refresh which means that only the change
data is loaded into the dataverse table
this helps to optimize data loading
performance and reduces the amount of
data that needs to be processed during
the ETL process
once the data flow is created and
scheduled it runs on a regular basis
such as daily or weekly depending on
your needs
the transform data is loaded into the
specified dataverse table and you can
then use it to power your apps reports
and dashboards
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering are
data connectors Microsoft Power Platform
is a system that enables users to create
comprehensive business solutions by
analyzing data through Power by Building
Solutions using powerapps and automating
business processes through Power
automate data connectors allow Microsoft
Power Platform to leverage data from
different sources connectors act as an
interface to connect to apis enabling
the underlying services to communicate
with Microsoft Power Platform popular
connectors include Salesforce Office 365
Twitter Dropbox SharePoint and SQL
Server
Microsoft Power Platform employs
connectors to efficiently utilize data
from multiple platforms connectors act
as a link between your data source and
your app or workflow allowing data to be
exchanged between them by utilizing
connectors you can expand your business
solutions to various platforms and
incorporate additional features for your
users
connectors allow apps to connect to apps
data and devices in the cloud there are
two types of data sources tabular and
function based tabular data sources
return data in a structured table format
examples of tabular data sources include
Microsoft dataverse SharePoint and SQL
Server function-based data sources use
functions to interact with data sources
examples of function-based data sources
include Office 365 users Azure blob
storage and project online those types
of data sources are commonly used to
bring data across many platforms and add
functionality to your Solution by
connecting to these data sources Power
Platform allows users to create powerful
apps automate processes and analyze data
from various systems and applications in
one centralized location
foreign
now that you have gained some knowledge
about data sources you are ready to
learn about connectors connectors act as
a link between your data source and app
workflow or dashboard Microsoft Power
Platform has over 600 connectors for
various data sources that are
categorized as standard and premium
standard connectors are free and
available to all users of Power Platform
these connectors are developed and
maintained by Microsoft and they allow
users to connect to a variety of
commonly used services and platforms
some popular standard connectors or
SharePoint Outlook and YouTube premium
connectors require additional licensing
for your app and or users freemium
connectors are created and maintained by
third-party vendors and offer more
advanced capabilities they may have
better performance more robust security
features or provide additional
functionality a few premium connectors
or SQL Server SurveyMonkey and MailChimp
connectors facilitate the exchange of
data between the data source and Power
Platform which can speed up the
implementation of Microsoft Power
Platform Business Solutions
one example of this is using Dynamics
365 apps such as customer service where
you can create a notification for users
through Power automate when certain
customer types are added you can use a
SharePoint document library to store
files that are then used in power apps
for management and distribution
Microsoft also offers connectors to
their Azure Services which utilize
Advanced AI techniques to perform tasks
like extracting text from images or
recognizing faces and images
additionally all Microsoft Power
Platform Business Solutions can be
utilized in Microsoft 365 apps such as
teams enabling users to run power
automate from within teams
[Music]
although Microsoft Power Platform
provides over 600 connectors users can
choose to create a custom connector to
expand their app's functionality by
accessing either a publicly available
API or a custom API they are hosting in
a cloud provider like Azure API stands
for application programming interface
and it provides a set of functions that
developers can use
connectors work by exchanging data
between apis and assembling functions
into powerapps or power automate since
these connectors are based on functions
they will call specific functions in the
underlying service of the API to return
the corresponding data building custom
connectors offers the benefit of
cross-platform compatibility meaning
they can be utilized in various
platforms like power apps power automate
and Azure logic apps
creating custom connectors you can
create custom connectors using three
different approaches using a blank
custom connector from an open API
definition and from a postman collection
custom connectors and Power Platform can
be used in various use cases including
why integrating with non-standard data
sources custom connectors can be built
to integrate with non-standard data
sources that don't have pre-built
connectors available this allows
businesses to bring data from these
sources into the Power Platform for use
in apps and workflows
to customize the existing connectors
custom connectors can also be built to
add functionality to existing connectors
such as adding custom authentication or
providing additional data transformation
options
three automating business processes
custom connectors can be used to
automate complex business processes that
involve multiple systems and data
sources this can help streamline
workflows and improve efficiency
for building apps for external users
custom connectors can be used to build
apps for external users such as
customers or partners that require
access to data from proprietary systems
or databases
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering are
triggers and actions triggers and
actions are two fundamental components
of the Power Platform once you have
established a data source and configured
your connector there are two types of
operations you can use triggers or
actions triggers initiate workflows when
certain conditions are met for example a
trigger can be set up to automatically
start a workflow when a new item is
added to a SharePoint list or when a new
email arrives in a specific mailbox
triggers can be set up in power automate
formerly known as Microsoft flow and
powerapps
actions are prompted by the user or
trigger and allow interaction with your
data source through a specific function
actions are used in power automate and
power apps actions can be anything from
sending an email or creating a new
record in a database to posting a
message in a chat application in power
automate and power apps users can create
custom actions by building flows which
are workflows that automate repetitive
tasks together triggers and actions
allow users to create custom workflows
that automate processes and improve
productivity by connecting various
services and applications users can
streamline workflows reduce errors and
save time Power Platform provides a wide
range of connectors and templates that
can be used to create these workflows
and users can also create custom
connectors and actions to suit their
specific needs
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be going into
greater detail of what power bi is at
its main components let's begin with a
brief overview Microsoft power bi is a
collection of software Services
applications and connectors that work
together to transform your diverse data
sources into coherent engaging visuals
and interactive insights power bi
enables you to connect to your data
sources clean and model your data
without affecting the underlying Source
visualize and share what's important
with anyone you choose your data could
be a simple Microsoft Excel workbook a
collection of cloud-based and
on-premises hybrid data warehouses and
many more as you can see from the image
you can use many data sources such as
Excel Cloud databases Microsoft Edge
Microsoft Access SQL databases and many
more you can use them with power bi and
generate all kinds of visualizations
reports dashboards Etc that will help
you find business insights within your
organization's data
thank you
the next topic we'll be discussing about
are the parts of power bi so power bi is
made up of several components that all
function together starting with these
three fundamentals first we have a
Windows desktop application called Power
bi desktop secondly we have an online
SAS service called the power bi service
and lastly we have power bi mobile apps
for Windows IOS and Android devices
power bi desktop power bi service and
power bi mobile apps are designed to let
you create share and consume business
insights in the way that serves you and
your role most effectively
now let's go over the power bi Concepts
data sets reports and dashboards are the
three main components of power bi they
are all organized into workspaces and
they are created on capacities so what
are capacities capacities or a Core
Power bi concept that refer to a set of
resources utilized to host and deliver
your power bi work capacities are either
shared or dedicated by share capacity is
shared with other Microsoft customers
while a dedicated capacity is fully
committed to a single customer dedicated
capacities require a subscription by
default workspaces are created on a
shared capacity so that's all for the
main components of power bi
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going over what workspaces
in power bir so workspaces are
containers for dashboards reports data
sets and data flows in power bi there
are two types of workspaces first we
have my workspace and then we have
workspaces so my workspace is the
personal workspace for any power bi
customer to work with your own content
only you have access to your my
workspace
you can share dashboards and reports
from your my workspace if you want to
collaborate on dashboards and reports or
create an app then you want to work in a
workspace
workspaces are used to collaborate and
share content with colleagues you can
add colleagues to your workspaces and
collaborate on dashboards reports and
data sets keep in mind that all
workspace members need power bi Pro
licenses workspaces are also the places
where you create publish and manage apps
for your organization workspaces can be
thought of as staging areas and
containers for the content that will
make up a power bi app an app is a
collection of dashboards and reports
created to provide important metrics to
the power bi consumers in your company
apps are interactive but consumers
cannot edit them app consumers and the
colleagues who have access to the apps
do not necessarily need Pro licenses so
that's a general overview of workspaces
in power bi
foreign
the next topic we'll be covering are
data sets in power bi so a data set is a
collection of data that you import or
connect to Tower bi enables you to
connect to import and combine many data
sets in one location data sets can
Source data from data flows data sets
are associated with workspaces in a
single data set can be part of many
workspaces when you open a workspace the
associated data sets are listed under
the data sets tab each listed data set
represents a collection of data for
example a data set can contain data from
an Excel workbook on OneDrive and
on-premises ssas tabular data set and or
a Salesforce data set there are many
different data sources supported data
sets added by one workspace member are
available to the other workspace members
with an admin member or contributor role
so what are shared data sets a shared
data set is a data set shared between
multiple reports it's important to
establish standardized data sets that
serve as the one source of Truth
discovering and reusing those
standardized data sets is also key
report creators can use optimized data
sets created and shared by expert data
modelers in your organization as a
starting point when building Reliable
Reports your organization can have
consistent data for making decisions at
a healthy data culture to consume these
shared data sets just choose power bi
data sets when creating your power bi
report
moving on to data set types so power bi
data sets represent a source of data
ready for reporting and visualization
there are five different data set types
and they can be created in the following
ways first by connecting to an existing
data model that isn't hosted in a power
bi capacity
second by uploading a power bi desktop
file that contains the model then by
uploading an Excel workbook containing
one or more Excel tables in our workbook
data model or uploading a CSV also known
as a comma separated values file
you can also use the power bi service to
create a push data set and finally we
use the power bi service to create a
streaming or hybrid streaming data set
an exception for this would be for
streaming data sets the data set
represents a data model which leverages
the mature modeling Technologies of
analysis services so that's the
different kinds of data sets for power
bi
[Music]
so the next component will be discussing
are reports at Power B I report is one
or more pages of visualizations such as
line charts maps and tree maps
visualizations are also called visuals
power bi allows you to create reports
from scratch import them with dashboard
shared by co-workers or have it create
reports when you connect to data sets
like Excel power bi desktop databases
and SAS apps for example power bi
generates a report using the Power view
sheets in an Excel worksheet when you
connect to it additionally power bi
Imports a pre-built report when you
connect to a SAS application
so there are two modes to view and
interact with reports there is reading
View and there is editing view when you
open a report it opens in Reading view
if you have the edit permissions then
you see edit report in the upper left
corner and you can view the report in
editing view anyone with an admin member
or contributor role can edit a report if
it is in a workspace they have access to
all the exploring designing building and
sharing capabilities of editing view for
that report the people they share the
report with can explore and interact
with the report in Reading View
when you open a workspace the associated
reports are listed under the reports tab
each listed report represents one or
more pages of visualizations based on
only one of the underlying data sets to
open a report select it you are
presented with a dashboard when you
first launch an app
select a dashboard tile that was pinned
from a report to see the underlying
report you might need to click a few
tiles before seeing a report because not
all tiles are pinned from reports
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going into detail on what
is a dashboard in power bi so a
dashboard is something you create in the
power bi service or something a
colleague creates in the power bi
service and shares with you it is a
single canvas that contains zero or more
tiles and widgets each tile pin from a
report or from question and answer
displays a single visualization that was
created from a data set and pinned to
the dashboard entire report Pages can
also be pinned to a dashboard as a
single tile
the visualizations you see on the
dashboard are called tiles
you pin tiles to a dashboard from
reports and each report is based on a
data set a dashboard is an introduction
to the underlying reports and data sets
selecting a visualization takes you to
the report and data set that it's based
on you can pin many kinds of tiles to
dashboards you can pin a tile from a
report pin a tile from another dashboard
pin a tile from Excel you can create a
tile in question and answer and pin it
you can pin an entire report page and
you can also add images videos and more
to a dashboard
let's take a look at some of the
advantages of dashboards first you can
see in one glance all the information
needed to make decisions you can monitor
the most important information about
your business you can ensure all
colleagues are on the same page viewing
and using the same information to
monitor the health of a business or
product or business unit or marketing
campaign Etc and you can create a
personalized view of a larger dashboard
and show all the metrics that matter to
them
so that's a general overview of
dashboards in power bi
foreign
users can get confused between a report
and a dashboard so we'll go over the
main differences between the two because
there will definitely be some questions
on it in the exam for the pages
capability dashboards can only have one
page whereas reports can have one or
more pages for data sources dashboards
can have one or more reports and one or
more data sets per dashboard reports can
only have a single data set per report
for drilling down in visuals this can be
done for dashboards only if you pin an
entire report page to a dashboard on the
other hand drilling down in visuals is
available for reports dashboards are not
available in power bi desktop reports
are available in power bi desktop you
can build and view reports in power bi
desktop you can't filter or slice a
dashboard you can filter a dashboard
tile in Focus mode but can't save the
filter however filtering is available
for reports there are many different
ways to filter highlight and slice for
favorites you can set multiple
dashboards and multiple reports as
favorites for natural language queries
this is available for both dashboard
words and reports but you'll need edit
permissions for the report and
underlying data set for set alerts this
is available for dashboard tiles in
certain circumstances but this is not
available for reports for the Subscribe
capability you can subscribe to
dashboard and a report so these are the
main capabilities you'll be using for
dashboards and reports there are a few
more but the list is simply too large to
fit
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going through template apps
for power bi so power bi Partners can
create power bi templates with little to
no coding and deploy them to any power
bi customer using the new Power bi
template apps you can create a set of
out-of-the-box content for your
customers and publish it yourself as a
power bi partner you can build template
apps that allow your customers to
connect within their own accounts as
domain experts they can unlock the data
in a way that is easy for their business
users to consume template apps are
submitted to the partner Center to
become publicly available in the power
bi apps Marketplace and on Microsoft
appsource
power bi template apps allow power bi
Pro or power bi premium users to gain
immediate insights through per package
dashboards and reports that can be
connected to live data sources many
power bi apps are already available in
the power bi apps Marketplace such as
the covid-19 US tracking report Google
analytics report and the Microsoft 365
usage Analytics
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering is data
modeling and visualizations power bi
desktop is a free application installed
on your local computer that allows you
to connect to transform and visualize
your data you can connect to multiple
different sources of data and combine
them which is often called modeling into
a data model with power bi desktop you
can create visuals and collection of
visuals using this data model which you
can then share as reports with others
most users who work on business
intelligence projects create their
reports using power bi desktop then
share them with others using the power
bi service
in power bi desktop you will begin to
create reports in the report View
there are five main areas you will be
working with first we have the ribbon
this displays the common tasks that are
related with reports and visualizations
next we have the report view or canvas
this is where visualizations are created
and arranged the data view allows you to
view all your data available in your
report it is an easy way to quickly
check data types and validate data the
model view allows you to visually set
the relationship between tables or
elements
our relationship is where two or more
tables are linked together because they
contain related data this enables users
to run queries for related data across
multiple tables
the third area we have is the pages tab
this area is where you would select or
add a report page located along the
bottom of the page
next we have the visualizations pane
this is where you can change
visualizations customize colors or axes
apply filters drag fields and more and
finally we have the fields pane this is
where query elements and filters can be
dragged onto the report view or dragged
to the filters area of the
visualizations pane
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
the types of visualization in power bi
so starting off with bar and column
charts bar charts are the industry
standard for viewing specific value
across different categories here we have
a visual example of a bar chart
displaying counts of visits by building
and here we have the chart in a column
chart format
so let's look at some more types of
visualizations in power bi
first we have cards these can be viewed
in single or multi-row
next we have kpis these display progress
toward a measurable goal
next we have Maps basic Maps these are
used to associate both categorical and
quantitative information with spatial
locations
then we have pie charts and pie charts
show the relationship of parts to a
whole
another type of visualization is the
question and answer visual this lets you
ask questions about your data using
natural language
finally we have tables tables work well
with quantitative comparisons among
items where there are many categories
these are some of the out of the box or
pre-built power bi visuals available
from the visualization pane in power bi
desktop and power bi service however
there are some instances where you need
a more custom Visual and these can be
found in appsource for power bi
foreign
as mentioned in the previous video there
are some instances where users will need
a more custom Visual and these can be
found in appsource for power bi so power
bi visuals are provided to the public by
Microsoft and members of the community
who then publish them to the app source
to make them available for use
these visuals can be downloaded and
added to your power bi reports Microsoft
has tested and approved these power bi
visuals for functionality and Quality
Power bi certified visuals or visuals in
the app source that were additionally
tested to check that the visual does not
access external services or resources
after importing power bi visualizations
from appsource updates may happen
automatically without further
notification
so what is appsource app source is the
place for apps add-ins and extensions
for your Microsoft software appsource
connects millions of users of products
such as Microsoft 365 Azure Dynamics 365
Cortana and power bi to solutions that
help them get work done more efficiently
and insightfully than before
next we have certified power bi visuals
certify power bi visuals or visuals and
appsource that meet certain specified
code requirements that the Microsoft
power bi team has tested and approved
the tests are designed to check that the
visual doesn't access external services
or resources
so that's a general overview of custom
visuals
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be going over filtering data
with power bi in a simple type of
filtering called a slicer so data is the
core of power bi as you explore reports
each visual draws its underlying data
from sources that often contain far more
data than you need filtering is a
technique used to focus on a subset of
data in the chart making it easier to
analyze and identify patterns or Trends
power bi offers several ways to filter
and highlight reports knowing how to
filter data is the key to finding the
right information when you filter a
visual like a bar chart you are just
changing the view of the data in that
visual you are not modifying The Source
data in any way remember to keep in mind
that filtering only applies to reports
not to dashboards a simple type of
filtering that you can use directly on
the report page is called a slicer
slicers provide cues to ways you can
filter the results and the visuals on a
report page there are several different
types of slicers such as numeric
categorical and date slicers make it
easy to filter all the visuals on the
page at once
so when should you use a slicer well
slicers are a great choice when you want
to display commonly used or important
filters on the report canvas for easier
access make it easier to see the current
filtered State without having to open a
drop down list filter by columns that
are unneeded and hidden in the data
tables and when you want to create more
focused reports by putting slicers next
to important visuals also note that
power bi slicers don't support input
fields and drilled out options explore
the filters pane another way to filter
data is by opening and modifying filters
in the filters pane the filters pane
contains filters that were added to the
report by the report designer as a
consumer you can interact with the
filters and save your changes but cannot
add new filters there are four types of
filters first we have report this
applies to all pages in the report then
we have page this applies to all the
visuals on the current report page next
we have visual this applies to a single
visual on a report page you only see
visual level filters if you have
selected a visual on the report canvas
and the last type of filter is drill
through this allows you to explore
successively more detailed views within
a single visual
[Music]
moving on to our next topic buttons in
power bi so using buttons in power bi
lets you create reports that behave like
apps and thereby create an engaging
environment so users can hover click and
further interact with power bi material
you can add buttons to reports and power
bi desktop and in the power bi service
when you share your reports in the power
bi service they provide an app like
experience for your users to create a
button in power bi desktop on the insert
ribbon select buttons and a drop down
menu appears where you can select the
button you want from a collection of
options as shown in the image
here are some key features and
characteristics of buttons and power bi
appearance buttons and power bi can be
customized with various shapes sizes
colors and text to fit the report design
action buttons can be configured to
perform a variety of actions including
filtering data navigating to a different
page or report opening a URL or file or
running a custom script interaction
buttons can be clicked by users to
trigger the configured action and can be
used to create a more interactive and
engaging report experience selection
buttons can be used as a selection tool
to filter or highlight specific data by
configuring them with a slicer or other
interactive element
integration buttons can be integrated
with other power bi features and
components such as bookmarks drill
through actions and visual interactions
to create a more Dynamic and customized
report experience
so that's a general overview of buttons
and power bi
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
power query editor so sometimes your
data might contain extra data or have
data in the wrong format you may need
additional columns or to rename or hide
existing columns you may have multiple
data sources and need to define a
relationship between them all these
tasks are known as data transformation
power bi desktop includes the power
query editor tool which can help you
shape and transform data so that it's
ready for your models and visualizations
power query editor is a data
transformation in preparation tool that
allows users to connect to and transform
data from a variety of sources like
Excel spreadsheets text files databases
and web services with power query editor
users can extract transform and load
data from these sources into Power bi
for analysis and visualization it
provides a user-friendly interface for
data manipulation allowing users to
filter sort group pivot and aggregate
data using a series of intuitive and
easy to use menus and tools it also
supports it's merging splitting and
unpivoting tables custom calculations
and Transformations a key feature of
power query editor is its ability to
create reusable data queries which can
be saved and shared with other users or
used to automate data refreshes this can
save significant time and effort for
users who need to regularly transform
and update large data sets
launch power query Editor to begin
select edit from the Navigator window to
launch power query editor you can also
launch power query editor directly from
Power bi desktop by using the transform
data button on the home ribbon in the
ribbon the active buttons enable you to
interact with the data in the query on
the left pane queries are listed and
available for selecting viewing and
shaping on the center pane data from the
selected query is displayed and
available for shaping the query settings
window lists the queries properties and
applied steps so this is the general
layout of the power query editor
foreign
so the next topic we'll be covering is
an aggregate at times there may be a
need to perform mathematical
calculations on the values within your
data the mathematical operation could be
some average maximum count and so on
this process of merging values in your
data using mathematical operations is
referred to as aggregation the outcome
of the calculation is known as an
aggregate
when power bi service and power bi
desktop create visualizations they may
aggregate your data in some cases the
resulting aggregate may be appropriate
but at other times you may want to apply
a different type of aggregation to the
data such as calculating the sum or
average of values
there are several different ways to
manage and change the aggregate power bi
uses in a visualization
typically data sets consist of multiple
types of data and at the simplest level
the data can be classified as either
numeric or non-numeric
Tower bi can aggregate numeric data
using a sum average count minimum
variance and much more additionally
power bi can even aggregate non-numeric
data which is often referred to as
categorical data
if you try to aggregate a categorical
field by placing it in a numeric only
bucket like values or tooltips power B I
will count the occurrences of each
category or count the distinct
occurrences of each category special
types of data like dates have a few of
their own aggregate options earliest
latest first and last
for example according to the image
provided units sold a manufacturing
price or columns that contain numeric
data segment country region product
month and month name contain categorical
data
here we'll look at some of the ways to
aggregate your data some of the options
that may be available for aggregating a
field do not summarize with this option
chosen power bi treats each value in
that field separately and doesn't
summarize them so then this adds all the
values in that field up average this
takes an arithmetic mean of the values
minimum this shows the smallest value
maximum this shows the largest value
count not blanks this counts the number
of values in that field that are blank
count the stanctive this counts the
number of different values in that field
standard deviation variance and median
this shows the median value this value
has the same number of items above and
below if there are two medians power bi
averages them
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering the power bi
security and administration power bi
like many other Microsoft Services
utilizes Azure as its foundation Azure
is the cloud computing infrastructure
and platform developed by Microsoft that
guarantees the same level of security
for power bi as other Microsoft Services
when users sign into Power bi they use
their credentials saved in Azure active
directory which permits them to control
the level of sharing for each report
data or dashboard
they can determine whether recipients
are permitted to edit or just view the
items
it's important to note that users are
responsible for the data they share
if a user connects to data sources using
their credentials they can share a
report or dashboard or data set based on
that data users with whom the dashboard
is shared are authenticated against the
original data source and will be granted
access to the report this is beneficial
to allow users to share reports and
dashboards they have created but does
require responsibility on the user's
part
power bi Administration is the
management of a power bi tenant
including the configuration of
governance policies usage monitoring and
provisioning of licenses capacities and
organizational resources power bi is
designed for self-service business
intelligence the administrator is the
guardian of data processes and policies
in the power bi tenant a power bi
administrator is a key member of a team
that includes bi developers analysts and
other roles the administrator can help
support an organization to make sure
that critical goals are met
so that's a general overview of the
power bi security and administration
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be starting off by creating a
Microsoft account so the first thing you
want to do is to go to this link here
called power.bi dot microsoft.com
us and this will take you to this page
here you can do this with other Power
Platform services like power apps or
power automate but since we'll be
starting with power bi we'll be using
this link and if you don't already have
a Microsoft account you'd want to
navigate to this button here and click
on the try free button so this is the
page where you would create your
Microsoft account and enter in your
email you want to register with and all
the other information required let's go
with this one Andrew Brown exam Pro
gmail.com
so for this method of registration you
will need a work email so you can't use
a commercial email account such as
Hotmail and Gmail
however there is another method to sign
up
this will require you to navigate to
this page microsoft.com
365 slash Enterprise slash compare Dash
office Dash 365-plans
this page provides you with a few Office
365 and Microsoft 365 apps plans such as
Microsoft 365 apps for Enterprise Office
365 E1 Office 365 E3 and office 365e5
there is an option to try for free and
this will allow you to access and use
all the apps on this list depending on
the plan they may provide partial use of
the app or some of the lower cost plans
may not include some features the key
apps that we're interested in are power
apps power automate power virtual agents
and power bi we'll be going with the
Office 365 E5 plan because it includes
power bi Pro so let's click on the try
for free button here we'll enter in our
email address Andrew Brown exam Pro
gmail.com
the list here shows all the apps and
services you'll be getting in the Office
365 E5 trial plan and remember that you
have a one month free trial so you have
to cancel the trial before that day to
avoid any fees
so click on next then click on setup
account
now we'll need to provide information
such as our first name surname business
phone number company name company size
and the country we reside in once we're
done that we have to accept the terms of
service
looks like we have to provide a
verification code let's enter that code
in and verify to proceed next we have to
create a domain name we'll try to keep
it simple so let's go with exam Pro
looks like exam Pro is already taken so
let's try to add a one it's available so
we can use this after that's complete we
can create a password and confirm the
password
then press next
next we'll have to add a payment method
so you'll need to enter in your card
information here and everything else
that is required once again you'll have
to remember to cancel before the one
month period to avoid any charges on
your card
after that's complete we'll have to
review all the information that we
entered in and confirm to start the
trial
it'll just take a bit to add the
products to our account but once that's
complete we can start using the Office
365 E5 trial so click on that
remember to use your domain email that
we just created to sign in so in this
case it's Andrew Brown at exam Pro one
dot on microsoft.com
enter in your password and click on sign
in
if you want to install Microsoft 365 on
your computer you can click on here I
already have it on my system so I can
skip this step for the domain we can use
the default exam Pro one dot on
microsoft.com for now
we won't need to add any users or assign
licenses for now
we can continue here as well
after that's all done we can go to the
admin Center
feel free to look around the settings
and features if you want to
but now that we have a Microsoft account
we should be able to log into the power
bi platform
so first we want to go back to the power
bi dot microsoft.com earlier at the
beginning then we want to click on the
sign in page we can use our Microsoft
account email that we created so we can
just copy that onto here then click on
submit this should log us into the power
bi service
now we have access to the power bi
service and we can play around with it
so that's how you can create a Microsoft
account
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be looking at how to build a
basic dashboard by using power bi so the
first thing you want to do is to go to
the power bi page at
app.powerbi.com home here you'll be at
the home page for power bi which will
have recommendations for you to go to
such as your recent workspaces what
you've frequently opened how to get
started and much more so on the left
side pane we have a bunch of tabs such
as create browse data Hub metrics and so
on before we create our own report and
dashboard let's quickly go through a
sample report that power bi has provided
for us so we'll click on learning under
samples we'll click on Revenue
opportunities
so now you're seeing a power bi Report
with nice visuals and a breakdown of the
revenue opportunities report we have the
opportunity revenue and opportunity
count on the top left there is the
opportunity count by region and pipeline
by stage on the bottom left the revenue
and opportunity count by month is
located on the top right and the revenue
by region and state is on the bottom
right they are presented with different
kinds of visuals like bar graphs line
graphs map visuals gradients and so on
we're also able to interact with the
visuals so if you want to filter out
certain regions metrics or any component
of the graph you can do that
for example if I only want to know the
opportunity count by region in the East
I can click on the East bar and it'll
only show and calculate the values and
highlighted areas for the results
on the left side page if I click on
detail it will show us the underlying
table that has The Columns of data used
to create the report
so let's go back to the report
and we'll click on the edit button in
the middle
this is where you can edit your entire
report you have many kinds of
visualizations available and filters you
can select the data you want in a
specific Visual and stylize it to your
liking on the right we have the
visualizations pane this is where you
can build your visual with all kinds of
charts like bar chart column chart line
chart scatter chart pie chart map chart
and many more so let's take a look at
the bottom left chart here it's
currently a stack bar chart but we can
click on stack column chart and it'll
change to it right away you can try out
other visuals and experiment to see if
it fits with the data selected
but let's leave it at the stack column
chart for now and if we click on the
format visual button in the middle we
can format the visual of the graph to
whatever we want there are many settings
we can change for example we can click
on columns then click on the colors tab
we can remove the conditional formatting
of the gradient and add in a solid color
or we can change the conditional
formatting of the color to what we want
we could also change the spacing of the
columns to match the size that fits the
graph or however thin or thick you want
you have plenty of other options such as
grid lines data labels and so on
there are also General properties where
you can edit the properties like the
height and size of the chart as well as
the position
and we can choose to leave the title
Auto or not
there are additional effects you can add
or change in the background visual
border Shadow and much more
on the right side we have the data pane
this shows all the data available that
you can use to create the visuals
so if we were to click on the pipeline
by stage graph we can see that it shows
the data that has been used in the
visual with the check boxes in this case
we've used opportunity count and sales
stage
we can select different Columns of data
and choose the kind of visual that fits
it best
for example I can choose something like
product code and revenue and it'll
change the graph using the data that
I've selected
we will also need to change the title of
the graph so we'll go to format your
visual then click on General and click
on title change the text of the title to
something fitting like product code by
Revenue
so you basically choose what you want to
display on your report using the data
that you have presented and stylize the
visuals to your liking
on the Middle top here we have something
called ask a question this is a pretty
neat feature where you can ask a
question about your data it will provide
you with suggested questions for you to
start out and you can show all
suggestions for more results so we can
test this out by clicking on something
like top states by factored revenue and
it'll provide us with the top states by
factored Revenue using the data we
provided you can select other questions
to try out or you can ask your own
questions related to the data
the next thing we'll be doing is
creating a dashboard okay so let's click
on the save button on the top right
next we'll click on pin to a dashboard
select new dashboard and we'll need to
give the dashboard a name so we can use
the same name as before Revenue
opportunities then click on Pin live
after that we can click on go to
dashboard
so this is the dashboard of Revenue
opportunities
similarly to the report we can interact
with the dashboard visuals and select
the key points of data that we want to
see there is also a drop down menu for
the product code to filter out the
product codes and more
the dashboard has a built-in question
and answer at the top so you can ask
questions about your data similarly to a
report it will provide you with a visual
of data that corresponds with the
question asked going back to the
dashboard we can edit the dashboard by
adding a tile or changing the dashboard
theme for example I can change the
dashboard theme from light to dark
making it easier on the eyes
for adding a tile we can add many
sources of media such as web content
images text boxes videos as well as
real-time data we won't need to know
this for the exam but you can play
around with the power bi features as you
like
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering how to create a
basic report in dashboard if you want to
create your own report and dashboard
instead of using a sample report you
will need a data set if you have your
own data set then you can upload by
going to my workspace here you can
upload your data from OneDrive for
business SharePoint or you can browse
from your own PC they must be a pbix RDL
or xlsx file I'll upload the sales data
economic analysis I downloaded earlier
if you don't have a data set at hand you
can search for what online there are
plenty of sources on the internet that
provide free data sets for you to learn
and practice for example you can go to
kaggle.com which is an online platform
that offers a variety of resources for
data scientists and machine learning
practitioners such as data sets and
tools to facilitate collaboration and
learning I found a data set here called
sales data for economic data analysis I
clean the data up a bit and trim some of
the data to make things less complicated
you can use whichever date data set you
find or what
another way to upload data is simply
copying or manually entering in data so
you can click on create on the left side
click on paste or manually enter data
from your Excel file Google Sheets or
any source that has a data set you can
copy and paste the data into the table
if your data has headers in the first
row you want to click on the use first
row as headers you also want to rename
the table so we'll rename this to sales
data economic
we can choose to Auto create report
create a blank report or create a data
set only but we'll choose autocreate
report to use as a starting point
okay here we are free to play around
with the current design we have
first we need to change this to edit
mode so click on that
then we need to change some of the data
on the graphs to the data that we're
interested in and to ensure that the
data makes sense because sometimes the
auto create report uses data like total
sum of age which is something we don't
want
so I've chosen the data that I want for
my graphs and the types of visuals that
look appropriate for them now we'll be
adjusting the size of the canvas and
we'll try to go for a different look to
do this we'll go to the format page then
canvas settings and we'll want to select
a custom type so we can change the
height and width that suits the report
we can enter in something like 1000
pixels height and 1200 pixels width you
can choose what you think is best
after that we'll be moving around the
graphs and visuals to see where we want
to place them or if we think it looks
suitable
we'll also be adjusting the sizes of the
graphs in visuals so it makes sense or
looks decent enough
I'll be speeding through this section
because it's mostly just adjusting the
graph's positions and making sure they
align well with the canvas so you won't
be missing out on anything too important
we want to try something a little unique
so we'll be providing it with a dark
background
you will need to go to format page then
click on canvas background
change the color to a dark color and
lower the transparency so that it's
visible
you can also use an image that you have
on your personal computer by clicking
browse
we'll be using a dark blue gradient
background we found with a simple Google
search
after seeing the white boxes I've made a
few more adjustments to the placements
of the graphs
we will need to remove the white boxes
from the graphs and text boxes so we'll
need to click on effects and turn off
the background
so we'll have to adjust the font to
White so it's easier to read
we'll need to do this for these visual
cards so it's the same process click on
category labels then change the font
color to white
then on the callout values also change
the font to White
for the graphs we'll need to turn the
background off so click on General then
click on effects then click the toggle
to turn the background off
then you need to click on visual then
click on the x-axis here you will need
to change the value font to White then
you will need to change the title font
to White
you will also need to change the font
color to white for the y-axis
you will need to change the title font
to White so you'll have to click on data
labels then click on values then change
the font to White
you will need to change the title font
to White
I realized I forgot to change the
transparency to zero so you'll be able
to see the dark blue gradient
so as you can see it's starting to look
better we'll continue to change the
fonts for the remaining graphs we will
apply the same steps like the sub of
Revenue by month graph so we'll need to
change the x-axis and y-axis fonts to
White and we'll need to change the color
of the title and data labels to White
and we need to turn off the background
so we'll be speeding through this
process since we already know how to
execute this
the bar colors look at bit plain so
we'll add a gradient effect to make it
look more interesting
to do this we'll click on format visual
then click on bars then click on the FX
button the default gradient color they
provided looks decided so we'll press ok
we also want to turn off the legend
since it automatically turned on once we
applied a gradient
we'll try to apply this to the other
graphs as well so we'll go through the
same procedure click on bars then click
on the FX button we want to keep the
orange color to mix it up a bit so we'll
try to find lighter orange for the
minimum then we'll find a darker orange
for the maximum
then click OK we'll also want to get rid
of the legend since it doesn't look too
appealing in my opinion
same process for the final graph we'll
also give it a gradient
okay so this looks fine it's not perfect
but it's definitely more interesting
than the default design that they
provided for us
after that you can save the report and
we can do the same thing as we did in
the previous video
pin to dashboard and Pin live
so all in all you can customize and
design the report however you want using
all the tools effects colors visuals
available in power bi until you are
satisfied with your design
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering power apps in
Greater detail power apps is a low code
no code platform developed by Microsoft
that allows users to build custom
business applications for web and mobile
devices it enables users to create
custom apps using a drag and drop
interface and pre-built templates
without the need for extensive coding
knowledge
with power apps users can create apps
that connect to various data sources
including Microsoft 365 Dynamics 365
SharePoint and SQL server and integrate
with other Microsoft services such as
power bi and power automate users can
also customize app functionality using
formulas and expressions and deploy apps
to web browsers or mobile devices
power apps can be used to create a wide
range of applications from simple data
entry forms to complex business
processes and workflows it can be used
in various Industries including
Healthcare finance and Manufacturing to
streamline processes improve
productivity and enhance customer
engagement
when modernizing a paper-based process
there are likely systems in your
organization with data you can leverage
power apps provides you with options by
offering a wide selection of connectors
that make it easy to connect to data
from a range of online and on-premises
sources this can be done using the
Microsoft dataverse which serves as both
a data service and an app platform or by
connecting to various other data sources
some common data sources included
dataverse SharePoint Dynamics 365 SQL
server in Azure SQL office
365. you don't have to choose just one
data source powerapps easily supports
multiple data connections allowing you
to bring data together from many
platforms into a single app
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering is
powerapps portals powerapps portals is a
low code web portal platform that allows
users to create and share custom
external facing websites that integrate
with their powerapps environment users
can build portals for a wide range of
use cases such as customer self-service
partner portals and employee portals
powerapps portals provides a wide range
of functionality including
authentication and Access Control Data
integration and custom branding it also
includes pre-built templates for common
use cases such as event registration job
applications and customer service
portals powerapps portals can be
customized using the same tools and
Technologies as other powerapps
applications including the common data
service canvas apps and model driven
apps this allows users to extend their
power apps environment Beyond internal
users to external users such as
customers partners and vendors overall
powerapps portals provides a powerful
platform for building external facing
web portals that are integrated with the
powerapps ecosystem making it an ideal
solution for organizations that want to
improve their customer and partner
engagement
through the powerapps interface you can
build an anonymous or authenticated
website that allows users to interact
with data held in dataverse the same
drag and drop experience you enjoy when
building apps is available to build
these rich interactive websites so
that's a general overview of powerapps
portals
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll cover is AI
Builder AI Builder is a Microsoft Power
Platform capability that provides AI
models that are designed to optimize
your business processes AI Builder
enables your business to use
intelligence to automate processes and
glean insights from your data in
powerapps in power automate with AI
Builder you can Leverage The Power of AI
without having any coding or data
science skills you can build custom
models tailored to your needs or choose
a pre-built model that is ready to use
for many common business scenarios
integration with powerapps and power
automate mix using AI easy to add
intelligence to your business why to
choose an AI model type use the model
type that suits your business need
choose from a growing set of AI
solutions to connect data select your
business specific data from the
available options three tailor your AI
model depending on the type of model you
can tweak custom models to optimize how
your AI performs for train your AI model
training is an automatic process it
teaches your AI model how to resolve
your business problem for example how to
recognize your products on an image
based on your business data and
tailoring when trained your AI model can
generate insights such as the result of
a prediction or the list and number of
objects detected in an image five use
insights from your AI model use the
results from your AI model across Power
Platform to create solutions that meet
your business needs even if you have no
coding skills for example you can create
a flow that automates document
processing in power automate or an app
in power apps that predicts whether a
supplier will be out of compliance
foreign
[Music]
you can use AI builder in Microsoft
power apps in one of two ways depending
on the model you will be using you can
use AI models in the formula bar or add
AI Builder components use AI models in
the formula bar you can get support for
the following AI Builder models that use
power apps through the formula bar here
is a table that shows the model types
available and the build types you can
use it's either pre-built or built and
custom for the sentiment analysis model
type the build type is pre-built for
entity extraction the build type is for
built and custom for key phrase
extraction it's pre-built for language
detection it's pre-built and for
category classification it's pre-built
and Custom
at AI Builder components AI Builder
provides two kinds of power apps
components choose your component based
on the models you want to use components
that use per built AI models that are
ready to use right away business card
reader for canvas app business card
reader for model driven app receipt
processor for canvas app and text
recognizer for canvas app components
that use custom AI models that you build
and train form processor and object
detector
the business card reader is an example
of a pre-built component that uses AI
components which can also be used in
other ways by creating a custom model
to create a model users can follow a
step-by-step process using the wizard
available on make.powerapps.com
currently powerapps offers four AI
models which are prediction this model
uses historical data to predict future
events form processor this model can
extract text from images such as with
the business card reader object detector
this model can identify objects and
images and provide a count of the number
of objects present text classification
this model categorizes text by its
meaning to facilitate analysis
the prediction model the AI Builders
prediction model allows users to
generate a model that can predict yes or
no outcomes based on historical data you
train the model by providing historical
data that includes the yes no outcome AI
builder takes care of the rest with the
prediction model users can create
solutions for various business problems
such as will Elite convert to a customer
will a project generate profit will a
customer stop using the product based on
their activity
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this section we'll be covering
the functions in powerapps in a bit more
detail
when working with Microsoft power apps
you don't need to have expertise in
writing complex application code like a
professional developer however you still
need to express the app's logic and
manage its features such as navigation
filtering and sorting this is where
formulas become useful
if you're familiar with Microsoft Excel
functions you'll find it easy to develop
apps using power apps to create a
formula you'll combine one or more
formulas with the necessary and optional
parameters
these are some common functions used in
powerapps and their purposes
filter this function is typically used
in conjunction with tables or galleries
of data to narrow down the rows
retrieved from the data source by
specifying one or more columns in your
data set to perform a logical test on
you can return data that falls within a
specific date range as a particular
value or was created by the user for
instance
match this function allows you to check
whether a value follows a specified
pattern you can utilize it to validate
if the user has entered a correctly
formatted email address and if not
display a warning message indicating
that a valid email is required this
function is particularly useful for
conditional formatting
distinct this function enables you to
retrieve the unique values from a list
of data simplifying the process of
creating Dynamic drop down menus that
display only valid values for a given
column
math functions powerapps features a
variety of math formulas for
manipulating your data ranging from
simple operations like sum and average
to more advanced functions such as aten
and sin for working with radians
[Music]
power apps can create three types of
apps canvas model driven and portals
each is suited to different scenarios
and end users the first one we'll be
covering are canvas apps
so canvas apps are a low code
application development platform that
allows users to create custom business
applications using a drag and drop
interface
with canvas apps users start with a
blank canvas and add controls such as
buttons labels and text boxes to create
a custom user interface users can then
connect these controls to data sources
such as Microsoft 365 Dynamics 365
SharePoint or other third-party data
sources to create data-driven
applications
canvas apps offer extensive
customization options allowing users to
modify the appearance and behavior of
controls create custom formulas and
expressions and integrate with other
Microsoft services
they can also be deployed to a variety
of platforms including web browsers and
mobile devices
canvas apps are best suited for
scenarios where a high degree of
customization and flexibility is
required such as when building custom
business processes or workflows
some common use cases and capabilities
of canvas apps include custom forms and
data entry canvas apps can be used to
create custom forms and data entry
interfaces that can be integrated with
various data sources like Microsoft
Excel SharePoint or Dynamics 365 this
makes it easier to collect and organize
data in a way that is specific to your
business requirements
workflow automation with canvas apps
users can build custom workflows that
automate business processes like
approvals notifications or routing of
work items this capability can be
integrated with power automate enabling
you to connect to over 275 external
services and apis
custom dashboards and analytics canvas
apps can be used to create custom
dashboards and analytics that display
key metrics and data visualizations in a
way that is Meaningful to your business
this can be integrated with powerby
allowing you to create interactive
reports and data visualizations
mobile applications canvas apps can be
used to create mobile applications that
are optimized for smartphones and
tablets this can be useful for creating
custom applications for field employees
sales teams or other remote workers
integration with other services canvas
apps can be integrated with other
Microsoft services like Dynamics 365
power automate and power bi this makes
it possible to create custom
applications that are tailored to your
specific business needs and that can be
integrated with other applications or
services
foreign
[Music]
apps has many different components to
build Solutions including screens inputs
galleries forms and more
power app studio is the web-based
interface that enables you to create
your app without requiring you to
download or install a separate client by
logging into https colon slash
make.powerapps.com from your browser you
can build your app entirely online using
powerapps
app for vet the first step in creating
your app is to choose the format of your
app mobile or tablet while both formats
are compatible with mobile device a
tablet or a computer each has different
defaults regarding the size of the
screens and controls once you choose the
format for an app you cannot change it
galleries the gallery control is used to
display rows from a table of data the
display of a row is then defined by a
template which you can customize to meet
your needs this allows you to control
which columns are shown and how they are
formatted power apps will then apply
this template automatically to every Row
in your data
forms forms are focused on working with
a specific record often based on a
selection from a gallery and this
experience a user browses a gallery to
find and select the desired row to view
the details on the form forms enable a
user to not only view detailed
information but to save new records and
edit existing ones the various actions
performed with forms are controlled by
Form nodes allowing the form to serve
many purposes
input controls powerapps provides a wide
range of input controls to offer maximum
flexibility while customizing your apps
these controls include text inputs
buttons drop-downs toggles date Pickers
and Sliders among others
you can seamlessly integrate these
controls into galleries forms and
screens to create an aesthetically
appealing and functional app furthermore
all these inputs come with various
settings for default data formatting and
actions empowering you to develop an app
that offers an optimal user experience
for your business process
intelligent controls in addition to
Common inputs powerapps also provides a
rich set of controls for more advanced
operations these include hardware-backed
controls that provide access to features
like the camera Barcode Scanner GPS and
other Hardware related functionalities
there are also service backed controls
like the business card reader and object
detector which enable you to incorporate
artificial intelligence into your app
without writing any code
functions functions play a crucial role
in connecting controls inputs and data
sources and power apps by using
functions you can create formulas that
perform various actions such as
formatting data sending data to a data
source or creating animations
these formulas are similar to excel
functions and do not require complex
coding they are easy to use and can
enhance the functionality of your app
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be looking at how to build a
basic canvas app
so before we begin we'll need a sample
data set that we can provide to
powerapps which will enable it to
connect and create a canvas app we will
need to navigate to this
pagelearn.microsoft.com and US slash
power Dash apps slash maker slash canvas
Dash apps slash get Dash started Dash
create Dash from Dash data this page
provides steps to create a canvas app
with data from an Excel file and
provides a sample data set we can use
there are many data connectors to use
but for this example we'll use an Excel
file you are free to use your own Excel
file but the data must be formatted as a
table so the first thing we'll have to
do is download the flooring estimates
Excel file I already have the file
downloaded on my computer so I won't
need to download it again once you have
it downloaded you'll want to upload this
file onto your OneDrive so you'll have
to go to the OneDrive this is part of
your Microsoft 365 account and is linked
to apps like powerapps power bi power
automate and other apps click on upload
then file then choose the flooring
estimates Excel file I already have it
uploaded on my OneDrive so I won't need
to upload it after you're finished
uploading you'll need to navigate to the
powerapps page to do that you can click
on the top left Square dots then click
on all apps then you can use the search
tool or you can scroll down to find
power apps click on power apps to open
the powerapps page
once we have arrived here we want to
click on create
as you can see there are many
connections to choose from but we'll be
using the Excel file we uploaded so
we'll click on Excel
so after you click on Excel you want to
click on OneDrive for business if you
don't have a OneDrive for business
connection already you'll be prompted to
create one by clicking the new
connection button then you'll click on
the flooring estimates file
choose the table and click on connect
here you will see an app that is created
with the flooring estimates data
you can press the play button or F5 to
preview the app and play here it
provides the entire list of items in the
Excel file that we provided it has
structured the data in an interactive
canvas app which displays the images and
details on each item and it includes
multiple functions such as a search
option new item button and more you can
click on the right arrow to view the
item in more detail it will provide the
category the image the name a
description and a price for the specific
item there is an edit button to edit out
the specific fields that we've mentioned
and there is a delete button to delete
the item
there's also a sort list button to sort
by alphabetical order
and a refresh button in case one of your
team members has updated the Excel data
set so you can click on the X on the top
right or press escape to go back to the
previous working canvas view also
there's a good tip here where you can
hold the ALT key to activate buttons and
other controls while you are working on
the app normally if you click on the
buttons you'll just select and highlight
the area and you can edit it but if you
hold the ALT key you can activate the
button in controls like this so you
won't need to preview the app and can
edit it while testing it
so on the left here shows a tree view of
all our items
and as you notice that with every item
that I'm selecting the things on the
working canvas are being selected as
well
you can see that things like next Arrow
one subtitle one search icon 1 and so on
are correspond to in the working canvas
so let's take a look at something like
the subtitle one here
on the right hand side it shows all the
properties that we can edit for the
specific item that we've selected
for example I can change the font weight
to bold which should reflect on the app
right away
I can change the text to something else
like Ariel
I can change the font color to something
like blue
or we can change it to something like
orange
but let's leave it the way it originally
was for now
so as you can see on the left in the
tree view this app is broken down into
three screens
there is the browse screen which is the
main screen you see with the list of
items
there is the detail screen which
displays the details of each item
and there's the edit screen which allows
you to edit the fields on a specific
item
and each one of these screens has its
own layout that is made up of buttons
forms functions items and such for that
specific screen for the user to interact
with
some of these buttons may have functions
as you can see on the function bar it
shows new form edit Form 1 and it
navigates to edit screen one but since
it's a fundamental course you won't need
to know each and every function and how
to use them at a high level
so we can do some small changes to this
such as adding a space to the flooring
estimates title to make it more legible
remember that this only applies to the
browse screen so we'll have to change
the for estimate title for the detail
and edit screen as well
you can insert all kinds of items and
controls such as text labels edit forms
buttons and many more
so overall there are many ways to
customize and design the way your canvas
app looks using any structured data set
you want
you can add data integration from a
variety of sources including Excel
SharePoint and SQL Server
and you can publish and share their
canvas apps within their organization or
even publicly
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering model driven apps
so a model driven app is a type of app
that is designed to present data in a
structured and organized way using
pre-built components and a data model
that defines the relationships between
different data entities
in a model driven app the user interface
is generated automatically based on the
data model which allows users to
interact with the app in a consistent
and intuitive way model driven apps and
power apps are typically used for
complex scenarios where data is stored
in multiple tables and there are complex
relationships between them for example a
model driven app could be used to manage
a customer relationship management
system where data is stored in tables
such as contacts accounts and
opportunities
the app would provide pre-built
components such as forms lists and
charts that allow users to view create
and edit data in a structured way one of
the key advantages of model driven apps
and power apps is that they provide a
high degree of flexibility and
customization users can modify the data
model to add new tables or fields and
they can customize the user interface by
adding or removing components changing
layouts and applying themes in summary a
model driven app in powerapps is a
powerful tool for building custom
business applications that provide a
structured and organized way to interact
with complex data models
[Music]
before we go more in detail on model
driven apps we'll go through the main
differences between model driven apps
and canvas apps the main difference
between model driven apps and canvas
apps and powerapps is the way the user
interface is designed and how data is
presented model driven apps have an
automatically generated pre-built
interface based on a data model while
canvas apps allow users to design the
interface from scratch using pre-built
components and formulas model driven
apps are best for complex data models
with multiple tables while canvas apps
are ideal for simpler models or highly
customized interfaces
here are some key differences between
model driven apps and canvas apps and
power apps user interface model driven
apps have a pre-built structured user
interface based on the data model while
canvas apps allow users to design the
user interface from scratch data model
driven apps are designed to work with
complex data models that have multiple
tables and relationships while canvas
apps are better suited for simpler data
models customization canvas apps provide
more customization options than model
driven apps but they also require more
design work development speed model
driven apps can be developed more
quickly than canvas apps because much of
the user interface is pre-built but they
may be less flexible in terms of design
overall the choice between model driven
apps and canvas apps depends on the
specific requirements of your
application if you need to work with a
complex data model a model driven app
may be the better choice well if you
need more flexibility in terms of design
a canvas app may be the way to go
in canvas apps the App Maker has total
control over the app layout with model
driven apps much of the layout is
determined by the components you add
here is a table to view the differences
between the two apps per category to
make it more digestible it's a bit
redundant to what we've already stated
but it doesn't hurt to reinforce the
information you'll need to know for the
exam
data platform for model driven apps its
dataverse only whereas for canvas apps
it's dataverse plus many others using
connectors design experience there is no
code component focused design for model
driven apps but for canvas apps there is
manipulation of control properties using
Power FX Expressions eui control for
model driven apps there is limited
predominantly customization canvas apps
have full control for model driven apps
the app consistency is high differs
predominantly based on the tables and
Views chosen for canvas apps it's often
low given the significant control the
designers have of the user experience
the migration between environments is
simple for model driven apps and
potentially complex given that the data
sources may need to be updated for
canvas apps speed of creation is rapid
for model driven apps and relative to
the complexity of the design for canvas
apps it's automatically responsive for
model driven apps and only responsive if
designed in this way for canvas apps for
model driven apps the navigation through
relationships is automatic provided
relationships exist and for canvas apps
it's only where designed and applied
using Power FX formulas accessibility
features are built in for model driven
apps whereas for canvas apps it's
designed into the app create accessible
canvas apps
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering the three design
phases of a model driven app so model
driven apps have three design phases why
to model your business data to Define
your business processes three build the
app model your business data model
driven design uses metadata driven
architecture so that designers can
customize apps without writing code to
model business data you determine what
data the app will need and how that data
will relate to other data metadata means
data about data and defines the
structure of the data stored in
Microsoft dataverse
you create a data model that defines the
structure of the data that the app will
use this includes defining entities and
the relationships between them you can
also Define data fields views and charts
Define your business processes defining
and enforcing consistent business
processes is a key aspect of model
driven app design consistent processes
help ensure that your app users can
focus on their work and not worry about
having to remember to perform a set of
manual steps processes can be simple or
complex and they often change over time
you define the business processes that
the app will support such as workflows
approvals and notifications
you can use the built-in tools and power
apps to create and manage these
processes
the screenshot illustrates the impact of
having a business process flow in place
build the app after modeling data and
defining processes you build your app by
selecting and setting up the components
you need in the app designer you create
the user interface for the app using
pre-built components such as forms lists
and charts the user interface is
generated automatically based on the
data model you created in the first
phase you can also customize the user
interface by adding or removing
components changing layouts and applying
themes
foreign
the next topic we'll be covering are the
building blocks of model driven apps
starting with data the table below shows
the different data components that can
make up a model driven app which can
determine what data the app will be
based upon it also shows what designer
is used to create or edit the data
component table tables or items with
properties that you track examples
include contacts and accounts many
standard tables are available you can
customize a non-system standard table
you could also create a custom table
from scratch column columns are
properties that are associated with a
table and help Define that table a
column is defined by a data type which
determines the type of data that can be
entered or selected examples of data
types include text number date and time
currency and look up columns are
typically used in forms views and
searches
relationship relationships Define how
tables can be related to each other
there are one and and one and then and
relationships for example adding a
lookup column to a table creates a new
one and relationship between the two
tables and lets you add that lookup
column to a form
choice this type of column shows a
control that lets the user select among
predefined options each option has a
number value in a label Choice columns
can require either a single value or
multiple values
user interface the table below shows the
user interface components which
determine how users will interact with
the app and what designer is used to
create or edit the component
app apps determine the app fundamentals
like components properties the client
type and the URL sitemap a sitemap
specifies the navigation for your app
for it forms include a set of data entry
columns for a given table a form can be
used to create a new data row or edit an
existing one view views Define how a
list of rows for a specific table
appears in your app a view defines the
column shown
Logic the logic components determine
what business processes rules and
automation the app will have Microsoft
power apps makers use a designer that is
specific to the type of process or rule
they are needing business process flow
business process flows walk users
through a standard business process use
a business process flow if you want
everyone to handle customer service
requests the same way or you can use a
business process flow to require staff
to gain approval for an invoice before
submitting an order workflow workflows
automate business processes without a
user interface designers use workflows
to initiate automation that does not
require any user interaction actions
actions are a type of process that lets
you manually invoke behaviors including
custom actions directly from a workflow
business rule business rules apply rules
or recommendation logic to a form to set
field requirements hide or show Fields
validate data and more app designers use
a simple interface to implement and
maintain fast changing and commonly used
rules
flows power automate is a cloud-based
service that lets you create automated
workflows between apps and services to
get notifications sync files collect
data and more
visualization the visualization
components determine what type of data
and Reporting the app will show and have
available in which designer is used to
create or edit the component chart
charts are individual graphical
visualizations that can appear in a view
or a form or that can be added to a
dashboard dashboard dashboards show one
or more graphical visualizations in one
place that provide an overview of
actionable business data embedded
Microsoft power via power bi ads
embedded power bi tiles and dashboards
to your app power bi is a cloud-based
service that provides business
intelligence insight
please
another important aspect of a model
driven app is the business logic model
driven apps are created using the app
designer users select tables dashboards
business process flows forms and other
components to be made available in the
app which will then be automatically
generated this means you will need to
spend more time understanding what your
user needs and how it is going to look
business logic when incorporating
business logic in your app there are two
primary options available you can set
business rules on your Microsoft
dataverse tables or you can build
business process flows
with business rules you'll Define
behaviors of the data layer business
rules are great for setting conditions
for when a field is required setting a
default value or even showing or hiding
a field based on criteria an example
could be a table for tracking expenses
you could have a column for type of
travel and then build a business rule
that dictates that if a user chooses
automobile then the mileage field is
required else it is optional this gives
you the power to make sure you maintain
data consistency in all scenarios
and powerapps a business process flow is
a feature that helps guide users through
a specific process or workflow within an
app they can be used to standardize
processes ensure consistency and improve
efficiency
a business process flow consists of a
series of stages and steps each with its
own set of fields and actions users can
move through the stages and steps to
complete the process and business
process flows can be set up to require
certain fields or data entry before
advancing to the next stage
they can be associated with specific
entities and power apps such as leads
opportunities or cases and can be
customized to fit the specific needs of
the organization additionally business
process flows can be used in conjunction
with other features in power apps such
as business rules to further enhance the
user experience and streamline workflows
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be providing a brief overview
of dashboards and power apps in
powerapps a dashboard is a user
interface that provides a summary view
of data from various sources dashboards
and power apps typically include
visualizations such as charts graphs
tables and other data driven components
that allow users to quickly and easily
View and analyze data in a centralized
location
powerapps dashboards can be customized
to meet specific business requirements
and can be created using various data
sources including Microsoft dataverse
Excel spreadsheets and SharePoint lists
users can also create multiple
dashboards and share them with specific
individuals or groups within the
organization dashboards and power apps
are an essential component of data
analysis and visualization providing
users with a clear and concise view of
key performance indicators Trends and
other critical business metrics
you can Implement dashboards with custom
filters and visual Graphics to tie all
this data together right in your app
when creating your dashboards make sure
they are simple for your users to
consume without overwhelming them with
all the data provide high-level
snapshots of your data and allow them to
use filters to dive deeper into the data
if needed
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this video we'll be going over a
sample of a model driven app
so the first thing you want to do is to
go to the powerapps page which is at
make dot powerapps.com here it provides
you with a lot of options to build
business apps you can start from blank
dataverse SharePoint Excel SQL and so on
let's start by using a template that is
already prepared for us this will give
us a better understanding of a model
driven app like the structure and all
the tables of data that are linked
together so we'll be clicking on the
create button on the left side panel
scroll down and look for the templates
as you can see we have a lot of
templates we can choose from but let's
take a look at Innovation Challenge
which is labeled as a model driven app
click on create
now that we have it loaded we can look
at this page in better detail so in the
center box is the model driven app View
on the left you can see the pages tab
currently open you also have other tabs
here such as navigation data and
automation we won't have to worry too
much about it as of now on the right
hand side are the properties that you
can edit or change depending on what you
are selecting it could be the content
type title icon ID and so on so let's
press the play button on the top right
to preview this model driven app
okay so what we're currently viewing
right now is a dashboard the use case
we're seeing generally involves
Gathering ideas and Concepts
transforming them into projects and
connecting them with larger business
strategies and this model driven app has
tables that are related to each other
and we want to be able to track all of
those things so this dashboard consists
of visually appealing charts and lists
of items that make it easy to see what's
going on and this application has three
tables in it we have challenges ideas
and team projects
so if we take a look at challenges this
will show us a view of tables consisting
of the name number of ideas launch date
accept new ideas and so on we can sort
however we like or filter by using more
advanced features we can also edit the
information on the tables if we wish to
so if we were to double click into one
of these challenges such as the
connected operations at the top here we
have a business process flow and this
guides the user across the stages and
steps of an end-to-end process that
you've made in your business that you
want to track manage and report on so as
you can see we have lots of different
fields of information such as the
description and order we have a drag and
drop with multiple different boxes you
can check like email teams and phone
we have a list of stakeholders at other
records so one challenge may be linked
to many contributed ideas and so on
I'm able to click on one of those ideas
and see something similar for example if
I click on the fleet automation idea you
can see another business process flow at
the top here
you can see the visibility of that
parent challenge record showing through
with read-only Fields here you can see
the investment required of fifty
thousand dollars the time to Roi of 12
months status reason is active the idea
score is 9 and the risk score is five
then the other thing we can do with the
business process flow is approve the
project stages manually and proceed to
the next stage however they must meet
the set of requirements and if we look
at the team projects tab we will see the
list of active team projects here we see
the fleet automation that we were just
on listing all the relevant information
on that so you can sort of see how the
tables and data are linked together
through many relationships and how it
can be sorted and transformed into a
dashboard as mentioned before this
dashboard is built using these three
tables challenges ideas and team
projects which is part of the Innovation
Challenge model driven app
thank you
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this video we'll be covering how
to create a basic model driven app or
specifically a simplified version of The
Innovation Challenge model driven app we
showed earlier so as we've mentioned
before model driven apps are built using
Microsoft dataverse and if we click on
tables you will see a list of tables
ready for you to use for common
activities or scenarios the most common
data tables user account and contacts
because when you are doing anything that
involves customers these will most
likely come into play you can choose to
use them or not but you'll see that
they're comprehensive you can add to
them or you can edit them in your app so
you've got that starting point so let's
click on Solutions
and click on Innovation Challenge
as you can see our Innovation Challenge
currently has no objects so we'll need
to create some if we recall the
Innovation Challenge at three tables
challenge ideas and team projects we'll
only be creating the challenge and ideas
tables for this simplified version let's
click on the new button then towards
table
so for the display name this will be
challenge we can enable attachments if
we want click on Advanced options and
here we have many options and boxes we
can select such as track changes setting
up SharePoint document management and so
on but what we want to select is the
create new activity this will create a
timeline that's going to be in the
middle now that we have a table created
we're going to need to create some of
the columns that were in The Innovation
Challenge app so let's click on columns
under the schema box as you can see
there's already a list of columns in the
powerapps environment for common use
cases such as created by created on
Modified by owner and so on you can set
up all kinds of ownership and security
and permissions which allows you to
control that at a very granular level if
we recall from The Innovation Challenge
app edit columns like description
duration accept new ideas until and
communicate via these aren't included in
the common columns that powerapps has
provided so we'll need to create them
and customize them similarly to the app
click on new column give the display
name is description
the data type will be text and we want
the multiple lines of text to be rich
text
click on Save
we'll now need to create the accept new
ideas until column so click on new
column again
the display name is accept new ideas
until
use the data type drop down menu to
select date and time and we'll select
date only
then click on save it
the next column We'll add is the
duration column so click on new column
the display name is duration weeks and
brackets and we want the data type to be
number and select whole number
click on Save
click on new column again
this column is the communicate via
column
the data type will be choice
and we want to choose the selecting
multiple choices as a loud checkbox
and on the bottom we want to select new
choice
the display name will be communication
here we'll be making the three choices
the first one is email click on new
Choice label the second choices teams
then the last label is phone we can add
color to the boxes to make them a bit
more visually appealing and easier to
distinguish by selecting the Box on the
left
after that's done click on Save
next we have to sync this Choice with
the communication choice that we just
created so search for that and select
communication
save that as well
okay now let's create the ideas table
click on new click on table
the display name is idea and we also
want to have the same features as the
first table so we'll click on the
creating a new activity checkbox so we
can have that timeline of activities in
it
let's add a column to the idea table
called investment required so same
process click on new then click on
column
the display name is investment required
for the data type it will be currency
click save
you can make the app as complex as you
want by adding it as many tables and
different things to it so the next thing
we're going to do is create something
called a lookup column for the idea
table this links these two together from
the idea table back to the originating
challenge table
so we'll click on new then select column
we'll name this origin challenge
the data type will be lookup
and the related table will be challenge
click on Save
so if we click on relationships from the
schema box
we should be able to see the origin
challenge that we created between the
two tables The Challenge and idea tables
are linked together through their
relationships you can also create
relationships here on the top left such
as many to one one to many and many to
many a lot of the work is already done
for you with the intersecting tables
behind the scenes so you won't have to
worry too much about that the next
component we want to look at is views
so click on views in the idea table
then click on active ideas
this is where you build your app
component you get to choose the columns
you want and do the filtering process
this is a drag and drop interface so you
can drag in the columns such as the
investment required column we just
created and we can add in the origin
challenge into the view
organize the columns and resize to your
fitting
we can also add and edit filters and
sorting orders so that it comes up
filtered by certain things you might
want to Only See
next click on Save is then click on Save
and click back to return to the previous
screen the next thing we'll be creating
is called a form
so you want to click on the challenges
table and click on forms
then you want to click on information
the form type is main should be fine
this is pretty much the skeleton and
structure of the table where you'll be
able to enter in information and create
challenges so in here you're able to add
different kinds of columns and headings
and things on the page on the bottom
right let's click on layout and change
it to three columns wide similarly to
the original app you can have one two or
three columns next let's track some of
the columns that we made that were for
the Innovation Challenge app accept new
ideas until can be placed on the top
right
communicate via can be placed below the
owner
the description Rich text box can be
placed between the name and owner we can
place the duration on the top right as
well
let's click on the components
we'll be adding a timeline in the column
here
and we'll be creating something called
the subgrid so we'll need to scroll
through and select the ideas table for
this and then the default view of active
ideas is already set click on done move
it over to the right column
so let's rename these labels because new
SG control with these numbers isn't very
helpful we'll name the separate as ideas
and we'll give the column label section
the contributing ideas we can rename the
middle column section to something like
events you can customize it to however
you're liking there are many features
and components you can add to it so this
should be similar enough to The
Innovation Challenge app so we'll click
on save a copy then click save it
next we'll return to the innovation app
page
this time we'll be creating a business
process flow which was the bar at the
top that takes you from the end to end
of the stages and steps of the process
so click on new drop down menu to
automation then process and click on
business process flow
we'll need to provide a name for it so
challenge process seems fine we'll need
to select which table it's related to so
we're using the challenge table click on
create
on the top left we'll need to add more
stages to the business process flow The
Innovation Challenge app had four stages
so we'll need to create three more
stages you can create as many as you
want but we'll keep it similar to the
original let's give the stages a name
just like the business process flow in
the innovation app
so the first stage is set up
the second stage is track
the third stage is Select and execute
and the fourth stage is close in award
in these stages we'll need to provide a
data step for each one of them so to
keep things simple we'll give duration
in weeks for the data fields in all the
stages if you don't have the data steps
set up you won't be able to activate the
business process flow
you can also add conditions and more
complex features but we'll keep it
simple in this app
after adding the data steps click on
Saved
then you can click on activate
okay so the next step is to create the
model driven app so click on new drop
down menu to app then click on model
driven app we'll give the model driven
app a name so Innovation Challenge app
is fine click on creative
next we'll need to add a page so click
on ADD page then choose the dataverse
table then click next
we'll be adding in the challenge and
idea table that we created into our
model driven app so click on ADD page
again dataverse table then click on next
find the idea table and click add
we also want to rename the group one on
our app so let's click on the navigation
tab click on Group 1 and rename to
something appropriate for the app like
innovation
next we'll need to click on the
automation tab on the left we'll need to
add our business process flow to the app
so we'll click on challenge process
after that click on Save then click on
publish
after that's done we'll go back to the
Innovation Challenge app screen and at
the top we'll click on publish all
customizations
once you see the publish all
customization succeeded notification you
can navigate back to the apps tab
here you should see the Innovation
Challenge app that you have created and
customized
so click on that
we'll need to enter in the challenges
that were in the original Innovation
Challenge app so click on new here we
can see the form that we created in this
same structure we have the business
process flow the name description odor
communicate via and so on just like the
original so let's enter in some of the
information the name is connected
operations we'll give that a description
and fill in all the other stuff after
we've finished entering the information
in and selecting the things we want we
can click on Save in the top
and once we go back we can see that a
challenge has been added to the active
challenges list we can choose to add
more challenges and ideas to the model
driven app to make it similar to the
original app
so as we mentioned earlier this is a
simplified version of The Innovation
Challenge app
you can play around with the tables the
forms views business process flows and
create what you want to learn more
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering power automate in
Greater detail so do you regularly
download email attachments before
uploading them to the database does the
process of authorizing a new purchase
order involve retrieving a form from a
physical location for signatures do you
have to manually visit a website daily
locate the daily numbers and then
transfer them to another system power
automate is a solution that can help
with these and other similar scenarios
it is designed to enable computers to
manage repetitive tasks with power
automate anyone familiar with the
business process can establish a
repeatable sequence that executes the
process when triggered common scenarios
and capabilities of power automate
automating repetitive tasks like
transferring data between systems
dieting a user through a multi-stage
process connecting to external data
sources using various connectors or an
API automating desktop based and website
processes with robotic process
automation capabilities
access to data is an important aspect of
app development and power automate
provides over 600 connectors to connect
to data and services on the web or on
premises some common data sources
included Microsoft dataverse Salesforce
Dynamics 365 Google Drive Office 365.
Microsoft Power Platform easily supports
multiple data connections allowing you
to bring data together from many
platforms into a single automation
additionally power automate enables
users to create custom connectors using
a Swagger file to connect to any data
source that is not covered by the
existing connectors
so those are the main values of using
power automate
[Music]
there are several types of flows you can
create with power automate power
automate works by creating flows of
which there are three main types
cloudflows business process flows and
desktop flows
cloudflows these flows are created with
a trigger in one or more actions and
there are many triggers and actions
available through connectors such as
receiving an email or a social media
mentioned
they are categorized as my flows or team
flows based on ownership with my flows
being owned solely by the Creator and
team flows having multiple odors
create a cloud flow to automate a task
that can be triggered automatically
immediately or on a schedule
automated flows these flows are
triggered automatically when a specific
event occurs in a connected application
or service such as arrival of an email
from a specific person or a mention of
your company in social media
instant flows these flows can be
triggered manually by the user through
the power automate mobile app the web
interface or other methods for example
instantly send a reminder to the team
with a push of a button from your mobile
device
scheduled flows these flows run on a
regular schedule or at specific times
such as daily data upload to SharePoint
or a database
business process flows these flows are
built to augment the experience when
using model driven apps in Microsoft
dataverse use these to create a guided
experience in your model driven apps
desktop flows these robotic process
automation flows allow you to record
yourself performing actions on your
desktop or within a web browser you can
then trigger a flow to perform that
process for you you can also pass data
integrate data out of the process
letting you automate even manual
business processes so these are the
types of flows in power automate
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering in
power automate or cloudflow templates so
a cloud flow template is a pre-built
workflow that automates a specific
business process or task in power
automate these templates are designed to
be easily customized and deployed
allowing users to quickly create and
share automated workflows that meet
their specific needs cloudflow templates
are available for a wide range of use
cases from simple data transfers between
applications to complex business
processes involving multiple steps and
approvals users can browse and search
for templates in the power automate
interface or on the Microsoft Power
Platform website and can also create
their own templates to share with others
you can choose from a collection of
templates to find the one that best
matches your company's scenario search
all templates or Browse by category to
find your scenario and then follow the
steps in the template to create a cloud
flow from the template
some common use cases for cloud flow
templates and power automate include
wide approval workflows templates can be
used to create automated approval
workflows for documents contracts and
other types of requests for example a
template could be created that
automatically sends a document to a
manager for approval when it is uploaded
to a specific folder
two social media monitoring templates
can be used to monitor social media
platforms for mentions of a company
product or brand this can help
businesses stay up to date with customer
feedback and respond quickly to any
issues
three data integration templates can be
used to automate the integration of data
from different sources for example a
template could be created that
automatically pulls customer data from a
CRM system and adds it to a marketing
automation platform
for a vet management templates can be
used to automate the management of
events such as sending invitations
tracking RSVPs and sending reminders
five document automation templates can
be used to automate the creation of
documents such as contracts invoices and
reports this can help businesses save
time and reduce errors
overall Cloud flow templates are a
powerful tool that can be used to
automate a wide range of business
processes improve efficiency and reduce
errors
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering are
the Microsoft power automate Concepts
starting with actions and triggers power
automate cloudflows use connector
triggers and actions to automate tasks
every flow has two main parts a trigger
and what are more actions
a trigger is an event that starts the
workflow such as a new email arriving in
your inbox a file being added to a
folder or a new record Being created in
a database triggers are used to initiate
the workflow and determine when it
should run
an action is a specific task that is
performed as part of the workflow such
as sending an email creating a new item
in a list or updating a record in a
database actions are used to automate
tasks and perform specific functions
based on the trigger
connectors are the bridge between the
triggers and actions allowing them to
communicate with other services and
applications
by using the appropriate connectors
users can create powerful and complex
workflows that automate a wide range of
business processes
connector triggers and actions are the
building blocks of power automate Cloud
flows allowing users to easily automate
tasks and streamline their workflows
some examples of types of actions you
can have in a flow include
Loops runs in action until conditions
are met to move to the next step of the
flow
switch identifies a single case to
execute based on the evaluation of input
due until executes a block of actions
until a specified condition evaluates to
true
apply to each executes a block of
actions for each item in the input array
Expressions underlying definition that
describes the actual logic that runs in
your flow that can be manually written
you can also perform data operations in
your flow such as compose create CSV
table join or select these Concepts will
come into play later when you build your
own flows from scratch
[Music]
the next power automate concept we'll be
covering in Greater detail or loops
a loop in power automate is a control
structure that allows you to repeat a
set of actions for each item in a
collection or until a specific condition
is met Loops are useful for automating
tasks that involve processing a large
number of items or performing a set of
actions repeatedly until a specific
outcome is achieved
the idea behind a loop is to make a
desktop flow repeat one or more actions
multiple times power automate implements
the simplest type of loops with the loop
action this Loop repeats the actions
between the loop and end actions for a
set number of times a loop index
variable is created automatically to
track the current iterations number
there are four types of Loops available
in power automate
apply to each Loop this Loop allows you
to process each item in a collection one
at a time it is useful for automating
tasks that involve processing a large
number of items such as sending an email
for each row in a SharePoint list
do until Loop this Loop allows you to
repeat a set of actions until a specific
condition is met it is useful for
automating tasks that require a specific
outcome such as waiting until a file is
available in a cloud storage service
before continuing with other actions
do while loop this Loop allows you to
repeat a set of actions while a specific
condition is true it is useful for
automating tasks that involve checking
for new data such as waiting for new
emails to arrive in a mailbox
for each Loop this Loop allows you to
process each item in a collection based
on a specific index or value it is
useful for automating tasks that involve
working with lists or tables such as
updating records in a database
these Loops are flexible and powerful
and they can be combined with other
actions and conditions to create complex
workflows
by using Loops you can automate
repetitive tasks reduce errors and
improve your productivity
[Music]
the next power automate concept we'll be
covering is a switch
in power automate a switch is a control
statement that allows you to perform
different actions based on the value of
a specified input the input could be a
string number or Boolean value
the switch statement evaluates the input
and Compares it to a set of defined
cases if the input matches one of the
cases the corresponding action is
executed if there is no match a default
action can be executed
here is a simplified example suppose you
want to automate an approval process
based on the amount of a purchase
request you could use a switch statement
to check the value of the purchase
request and perform different actions
based on the amount for example if the
purchase request is less than one
hundred dollars send an approval email
to the manager if the purchase request
is between one hundred dollars and one
thousand dollars send an approval email
to the department head if the purchase
request is more than one thousand
dollars send an approval email to the
CEO
here is a simple visual of a switch
layout
so it identifies a single case to
execute based on the evaluation of
switch input you have a value that's
passed through in case that checks to
see if it matches if the case does match
those actions are run however if there
are no cases that match then the default
cases run by using a switch statement
you can simplify your workflow and
reduce the amount of branching logic you
need to write you can also easily add
new cases as your business requirements
change
thank you
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be going
through are conditions in power automate
a condition is a control statement that
allows you to test whether a specific
condition is true or false and execute
different actions depending on the
result
conditions are used to make decisions in
your workflow based on the data that is
being processed for example you may have
a condition in your workflow that checks
whether the value of a field in a
SharePoint list is equal to a specific
value if the condition is true the
workflow might continue to The Next Step
such as sending an email or updating
another field in the list if the
condition is false the workflow might
take a different action such as
terminating the workflow or notifying a
user of the error
power automate supports a variety of
different conditions such as equals
greater than less than contains starts
with ends with and more you can also
combine conditions using logical
operators such as and or and not to
create more complex conditions to use a
condition in your workflow you typically
add a condition action to your workflow
specify the condition you want to
evaluate and then specify the actions
you want to take based on whether the
condition is true or false using
conditions in power automate allows you
to create more intelligent and flexible
workflows that can make decisions based
on the data being processed and take
appropriate actions based on those
decisions
foreign
automate an expression is a Formula or a
string of code that performs a specific
operation or manipulation on data they
are used to perform calculations
manipulate text and evaluate conditions
among other things
Expressions can be used in various
places within power automate such as
within actions conditions or dynamic
content
for example you can use an expression to
calculate a date based on the current
date extract the substring from a text
string or evaluate the result of a
condition
expressions in power automate uses
syntax similar to that used in
programming languages with functions
operators and variables power automate
provides a rich set of built-in
functions that you can use in your
Expressions such as string manipulation
functions date and time functions and
mathematical functions
in addition to the built-in functions
you can also create custom Expressions
by combining multiple functions and
operators to perform more complex
operations expressions in power automate
also support Dynamic content which
allows you to reference data from
previous steps in your workflow
using expressions in power automate
allows you to perform complex operations
on your data and automate your workflows
more efficiently by leveraging the power
of Expressions you can create more
flexible and robust workflows that meet
your specific business requirements
here are some examples of how
Expressions can be used in power
automate Dynamic email subject you can
use Expressions to create a dynamic
email subject line that includes data
from your workflow for example you could
include the name of the customer or the
ID of the record that triggered the
workflow
date and time calculations you can use
Expressions to perform calculations on
dates and times such as adding or
subtracting days or hours from a date
this can be useful in scheduling
workflows or setting reminders
conditional actions you can use
expressions and conditional actions to
evaluate data and make decisions based
on that data for example you could check
if a value is greater than a certain
threshold or if a string contains a
specific word
data Transformations you can use
Expressions to transform data from one
format to another for example you could
convert a string to a number or a date
to a string
array manipulations you can use
Expressions to manipulate arrays of data
such as filtering sorting or joining
arrays
data validation you can use Expressions
to validate Data before performing an
action for example you could check if a
field is blank or if a value is within a
certain range
foreign
[Music]
automate and approval is a type of
action that allows you to send a request
for approval to one or more individuals
the approval action can be used to
automate the approval process for
various tasks such as expense reports
time off requests or document approvals
when an approval action is triggered a
request is sent to the designated
approver with the relevant information
and options for approving or rejecting
the request
approvers can review the request and
provide comments if necessary before
making a decision once a decision is
made the workflow can proceed to the
next action based on the approver's
response
the approval action in power automate
provides several customization options
such as setting approval conditions
adding custom messages or attachments
and specifying escalation rules
the approval action can also be
integrated with other services such as
Microsoft teams or Outlook to provide a
seamless approval process within a
familiar interface
approvals actions actions are the events
you want your flow to perform after the
trigger starts the flow for example when
a new item is added to a list created
with Microsoft lists trigger and
approval to have somebody review the new
item this image shows the full list of
approval actions that you can use in
your flows
there are four approval types you can
use approve reject everyone must approve
all approvers are given to auctions
approve or reject a response is needed
from each approver before the flow run
is completed the actions that follow the
start and wait for an approval action
run after all the approvers respond or
when a single rejection occurs
approve reject first to respondent
assigned approvers are given two options
approve or reject approval or rejection
by any approver completes the request
the actions that follow the start and
wait for an approval action run after
any one of the approvers gives approval
custom responses wait for all responses
you define the options the assigned
approvers can choose from all approvers
must respond to complete the process
custom responses wait for one response
you define the options the assigned
approvers can choose from a response
from any approver completes the process
so that's a general overview of
approvals in power automate
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering the use cases for
power automate with some of Microsoft's
popular services like Microsoft teams
Outlook SharePoint and forms
starting off with Microsoft teams
automatically create teams and channels
for new projects or teams send
notifications to teams when new items
are added to SharePoint or other apps
automatically create a teams meeting
from an Outlook calendar event using
power automate set up a flow that
automatically posts a message to A
team's Channel when a new file is added
to a OneDrive folder Outlook
automatically create calendar events
from emails or create emails from
calendar events send automated emails
based on specific triggers such as new
leads or completed tasks
save email attachments to OneDrive or
SharePoint for easy access and
collaboration
automatically send an email notification
when a new item is added to a SharePoint
list using power automate
SharePoint automatically create
SharePoint list items from form
submissions or emails send notifications
when items are added or updated in
SharePoint lists automate document
approval processes and workflows such as
document review and approval publishing
And archiving automatically save
attachments to SharePoint libraries and
folders for easy collaboration and
document management
forms automatically create tasks
calendar events or SharePoint list items
based on form submissions send custom
confirmation emails or approval requests
based on specific form responses
automatically create charts or
dashboards based on form data to
visualize responses and Trends use
branching logic to customize the form
experience based on specific responses
such as showing or hiding specific
questions or sections
these are just a few examples of the
many use cases for power automate with
Microsoft teams Outlook SharePoint and
forms Tower automate can be used to
automate and streamline many different
types of business workflows and can be
customized to meet the specific needs of
your organization
foreign
[Music]
automate platform is accessible through
various apps and portals power automate
for desktop power automate mobile and
the power automate portal the first one
we'll be covering is power automate for
desktop so power automate for desktop is
a desktop base app that allows users to
create and run workflows on their local
machine this app is useful for
automating tasks that involve local
files and applications power automate
for desktop provides a graphical user
interface that allows users to drag and
drop activities conditions and other
workflow elements to build automation
workflows it supports a wide range of
actions including running Powershell
scripts reading and writing to Excel
files automating web browser
interactions and many others
power automate mobile power automate
mobile is a mobile app available on IOS
and Android devices this app enables
users to create manage and run workflows
from their mobile devices
with power automate mobile users can
create and run flows browse and search
for existing flows and receive push
notifications when a flow completes or
requires their attention
it also supports location-based triggers
allowing users to automate workflows
based on their current location power
automate mobile allows users to access
various connectors that enable them to
integrate with other applications in
service these connectors include popular
business applications like Salesforce
Dynamics 365 and SharePoint as well as
services like Twitter Dropbox and
OneDrive
Tower automate portal
the power automate portal is a web-based
portal that enables users to create
manage and run workflows from any web
browser
the portal provides a graphical
interface for building workflows and
offers various templates to help users
get started quickly
the portal also provides access to
various connectors that allow users to
integrate with other applications and
services
users can create custom forms and pages
that allow external users to submit
requests access data or initiate
workflows
it provides a range of features such as
user authentication and authorization
role-based access control and
integration with other business
applications that enable users to create
secure and scalable portals in summary
power automate provides users with
multiple options to build manage and run
workflows on different platforms
including desktop mobile and web-based
portals this flexibility allows users to
automate their workflows and streamline
their business processes regardless of
their location or the device they are
using
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering actions for power
automate desktop flows Tower automate
desktop flows offer a wide range of
actions that enable users to automate
various tasks on their desktop such as
file management data processing web
Automation and more here are some common
actions available for power automate
desktop file system power automate
desktop allows users to perform various
file system tasks such as creating
deleting moving copying and renaming
files and folders Excel users can
perform actions on Excel spreadsheets
such as opening closing Reading Writing
and formatting data email power automate
desktop can automate email tasks such as
sending and receiving emails downloading
attachments and extracting data from
emails web automation users can automate
web-based tasks such as web scraping
filling out web forms and interacting
with web pages
image recognition power automate desktop
offers image recognition capabilities
that allow users to automate tasks based
on image recognition such as clicking on
a specific button or selecting a
specific item from a list
text processing users can perform text
processing tasks such as searching
replacing splitting and parsing text
database power automate desktop can
interact with various databases such as
SQL Server MySQL and Oracle to perform
actions such as Reading Writing and
querying data system users can automate
various system level tasks such as
running applications capturing
screenshots sending keystrokes and
managing system processes overall power
automate desktop provides users with a
powerful set of actions that they can
use to automate a wide range of tasks
and processes on their Windows based
computers
it enables users to save time and
increase productivity by automating
repetitive tasks and processes
[Music]
the next topic we'll be going through is
document processing and power automate
refers to the automation of tasks
related to the processing of documents
such as PDFs images and text files
with the document processing
capabilities in power automate users can
automate various tasks related to
document processing such as extracting
data from documents converting documents
from one format to another and
processing large volumes of documents
here are some of the document processing
features available in power automate
optical character recognition also known
as OCR is a technology that converts
scanned documents or images into
editable text power automates OCR
capability enables users to extract text
from scanned documents images or PDFs
this feature is useful for automating
data entry tasks or extracting
information from documents such as
invoices or receipts
foreign processing power automates form
processing feature allows users to
extract data from structured forms such
as surveys feedback forms or job
applications this feature uses machine
learning models to recognize and extract
data from form Fields eliminating the
need for manual data entry
PDF generation power automate allows
users to generate PDF documents from
various sources such as templates data
sources or web pages this feature is
useful for automating document
generation tasks such as creating
invoices contracts or reports
document conversion power automate can
convert documents from one format to
another such as PDF to Word Excel to CSV
or HTML to PDF this feature is useful
for automating document conversion tasks
or preparing documents for further
processing
document approval power automate offers
document approval workflows that enable
users to review approve or reject
documents this feature is useful for
automating document approval tasks such
as purchase orders invoices or contracts
overall power automates document
processing features offer a powerful set
of tools to automate document processing
tasks making them faster and more
accurate these features enable users to
streamline document workflows reduce
errors and increase productivity
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
AI builder in power automate to take
advantage of AI capabilities you must
first build a model with AI Builder AI
builder in power automate provides
several types of pre-built models that
can be used for various purposes object
detection this model can be used to
detect and identify specific objects
within an image form processing this
model can extract key data from forms
such as invoices receipts and surveys
prediction this model can be used to
make predictions based on historical
data text classification this model can
classify text into different categories
sentiment analysis this model can
analyze text to determine the sentiment
of the text business card reader this
model can extract key information from
business cards such as name phone number
and email language detection this model
can detect the language of a text
keyword extraction this model can
extract important keywords from a text
entity extraction this model can
identify and extract key entities from a
text these pre-built models can be
customized and trained to meet specific
business needs or users can create their
own models from scratch using AI
Builders drag and drop interface
foreign
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and in this video we'll be showing you
how to build a basic power automate flow
so the first thing you'll want to do is
to go to the power automate page at
make.powerautomate.com
here we are currently at the home page
and it shows you all the things you can
do like what would you like to automate
and you can choose specific tasks that
you want to quickly automate with a
pre-built template and on the left it
shows a big list of things as well like
approvals my flows create and so on what
we're interested here are the templates
because these are pre-built templates
that make our lives a lot easier most of
the time there will be a scenario where
power automate already has it created
for you so you'll just have to enter a
few fields for the trigger and actions
and you'll be ready to go as you can see
there are hundreds of templates
available for you to fit your scenario
there are various types of templates
such as scheduled automated and instant
some examples could be email automation
approvals data collection and they can
connect to other platforms like power bi
teams Outlook and much more for this
example we can try something simple like
saveoutlet.com email attachments to your
OneDrive so whenever you receive an
email that has attachments in your
outlook inbox it will also save those
attachments in your OneDrive this can be
useful in case you may forget something
or you want to store important files in
your OneDrive all of this is automated
for you once you input a few fields of
information we could also try something
related to Microsoft teams for example
we can search for teams
something like send an email when a new
message is added in Microsoft teams
looks very simple and straightforward so
this will send an email to whoever you
select when a new message is added in
teams this can be useful for alerting
teammates that may not have access to
teams at the moment or sending important
messages that may be on teams but was
not sent to your email
so let's take a look at that
for this flow we'll need to connect to
our Microsoft teams account and our
Office 365 Outlook I already have my
account connected so I won't need to
connect again but if it's your first
time you'll probably need to connect to
these apps click on continue so on the
top area is the trigger which is when a
new channel message is added here you'll
need to select the team so this could be
your sales and marketing team your
development team or testing team and so
on for this example we'll choose
development and in this section we'll
need to select the channel That the
message is in so we'll choose emails the
next part is your action so this sends
the email you'll need to select who you
want to send the email to for this
section I will select my own email so
Andrew Brown I could select someone else
from the team but for this example I'll
just leave it for myself
this subject is new message on Microsoft
teams Channel this should be finances is
unless you want to change it up a bit
you can customize the body however you
like you can add Dynamic content which
allows users to pass data between
different actions in a flow making the
flow more flexible and efficient users
can extract data from various sources
and use them as input to automate
workflows without having to hard code
them into the flow Dynamic content can
include information such as email
addresses file names dates and other
data elements that can be passed between
different actions in a flow
so if we were to delete the message from
we can simply add the dynamic content
called message from user display name we
won't have to change anything here since
it's a simple automated flow
next we'll click on Save
and that's it your flow is ready to go
you can go test this out by sending a
message in the team's Channel and see if
it sends you an email
so I'm on my teams right now currently
at the email Channel which is where I
set up my automated flow to be here I'll
type in something like this is a test
after a moment we should receive the
email at our Outlook
so as you can see we have received the
automated email from teams so the
automated flow works great
let's try to make another flow we can
try to not use a template this time
instead we'll start from blank
so this is the trigger section where
there are many to choose from we'll try
something simple like when a file is
created in one drive
so click on that and click on create
it's a very similar process to the
previous method but here you have a bit
more freedom
so for the folder we'll select
development
and for the action we can choose
whatever action we want and you can have
as many actions as you need as well
so we'll go with something email related
like send an email let's search for
email in the search bar
and let's click on send an email
so same thing as before we'll enter in
the fields
I'll send this to myself so Andrew Brown
this is where Dynamic content is very
helpful since the fields aren't filled
in for you when you create it from blank
the subject can be the file name
and the body could be the file
identifier you can give it a title if
you want but the ones they generate for
you are decent enough
after that you just press save
and this automated flow should be ready
to use
so this is pretty straightforward and
helpful with automating repetitive tasks
and much more
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering power virtual
agents in Greater detail including its
main features and components power
virtual agents provides teams with a
simple and intuitive way to create
powerful chat Bots using a guided no
code graphical interface without the
need for technical expertise or coding
knowledge
it effectively addresses common
challenges associated with bot building
including the disconnect between subject
matter experts and development teams as
well as delays in updating Bots to
address issues by eliminating the need
for complex coding and Technical
knowledge our virtual agent streamlines
the bot building process and reduces the
it resources required to deploy and
maintain custom conversational Solutions
using power virtual agents you can
Empower your teams by allowing them to
easily build chat Bots themselves
without needing intermediaries coding or
AI expertise
reduce costs by easily automating common
inquiries and freeing human agent time
to deal with more complex issues
improve customer satisfaction by
allowing customers to self-help and
resolve issues quickly 24 7 using Rich
personalized bot conversations
some of the ways that power virtual
agent spots have been used included tow
vid19 infection rate and tracking
information sales help and support
issues opening hours and store
information employee health and vacation
benefits and common employee questions
for businesses power virtual agencies
available as both the Standalone web app
and is a discrete app within Microsoft
teams
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering are the
features of power virtual agents why to
get started in seconds Tower virtual
agents as a software is a service
offering it allows you to easily sign up
create your chat bot and embed it into
your website with just a few clicks
there is no infrastructure to maintain
or complex systems to deploy to empower
your subject matter experts using
powered virtual agents you have full
control your smes can create chat Bots
quickly and easily using a novel
intuitive code free graphical interface
eliminating the need for AI expertise or
teams of developers three enable Rich
natural conversations
Microsoft's Advanced conversational AI
technology enables end users to engage
in multi-turn conversations that
effectively and quickly guide them to
the correct solution there is no need to
retrain AI models
simply provide a few examples of the
topic you want the chatbot to handle
utilize the graphical Editor to build
the conversation and your chatbot will
be ready to respond to customer requests
Additionally the test pane feature
allows you to preview and test any
changes made in real time for enable
chat Bots to take action chat Bots that
can chat with your users are great but
chat Bots that can act on their behalf
are even better power virtual agents
provides the capability to integrate
with services and back-end systems
throughout-of-the-box integration or via
custom connectors that can be easily
added through Power automate this makes
it simple to create a chatbot that not
only responds to the user but also acts
on their behalf 5. Monitor and improve
chatbot performance power virtual agents
offers Advanced metrics and AI driven
dashboards that enable you to monitor
the performance of your chat Bots easily
track which topics are successful and
identify areas where the chatbot could
improve allowing you to make quick
changes to improve performance six
Better Together power virtual agents and
Dynamics 3cm 65 customer service
insights work seamlessly together to
provide a comprehensive perspective of
your customer service operations by
utilizing both platforms you can
identify trending topics or support
resource consumption and then easily
automate those tasks
foreign
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering the components of
power virtual agents starting off with
topics Empower virtual agents a topic
defines how a chatbot conversation plays
out you have the option to customize
existing templates create new topics
from scratch or use suggestions from
existing help sites to develop these
topics a topic has trigger phrases these
are phrases keywords or questions that a
user is likely the type that is related
to a specific issue and conversation
nodes these are what you use to define
how a chatbot should respond and what it
should do the AI leverages natural
language understanding to interpret what
a customer types and identify the most
suitable trigger phrase or node for
example if a customer types open hours
into the chat bot the AI can match it to
the store hours topic and initiate a
conversation that asks which store the
customer is interested in and displays
the hours of operation for that store
use system and Sample topics when you
create a chat bot a number of topics
will be automatically created for you
for per populated user topics that are
titled as lessons these lesson topics
provide guidance on creating simple to
complex chatbot conversations using
nodes a number of system topics these
are for populated topics that you are
likely to need during a chatbot
conversation they are recommended to be
used until you are comfortable with
creating an end-to-end chatbot
conversation you can edit both topic
types in the same manner as for topics
you create however you cannot delete
them
[Music]
the next component of power virtual
agents will be covering are entities
Empower virtual agents natural language
understanding plays a significant role
in chatbot conversations by allowing the
AI to understand a user's intent
for example if a user says I'm having
trouble using my gift card the chatbot
can recognize the user's intent and
direct them to the relevant topic about
Gift Card issues natural language
understanding involves identifying
entities in a user's dialogue an entity
represents a type of real world subject
such as a phone number zip code city or
person's name pre-built entities power
virtual agents provides a range of
pre-built entities that represent
commonly used information in real world
conversations such as age colors numbers
and names these entities allow the
chatbot to intelligently identify
relevant information from user inputs
and save it for later use custom
entities
while the pre-built entities in power
virtual agents cover frequently used
information types there may be instances
where you need to train the chatbots
language understanding model with
specialized knowledge that is specific
to the chatbot's domain or purpose
the next component of power virtual
agents or actions by using Microsoft
power automate flows you can enable your
chatbot to execute actions such as
automating activities or calling
back-end systems for example you can use
flows with end user authentication to
retrieve information about a user after
they sign in
you can call flows from within topics as
a discrete call in action node you can
utilize flows that have already been
created in your powerapps environment
where you can create a flow from within
the power of virtual agents authoring
canvas
so that's a general overview of entities
and actions in power virtual agents
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering is
publishing power virtual agents chat
Bots power virtual agents allows you to
publish chat bots on various platforms
or channels such as websites mobile apps
and messaging platforms like Microsoft
teams and Facebook after you have
published at least once you can connect
your chatbot to additional channels any
updates to your chatbot require
republishing it from the power virtual
agents app which will update the chatbot
across all channels where you've
inserted or connected your chatbot
Additionally you can configure a power
virtual agents chatbot to provide
authentication capabilities so users can
sign in with any oauth 2 identity
providers such as Azure active directory
a Microsoft account or Facebook
steps to publish a power virtual agents
chatbot why in the power of virtual
agents portal navigate to the authoring
canvas for the chatbot you want to
publish to click on the publish button
in the top right corner of the screen
three on the publish page review the
information provided including the
version number and the changes that will
be published
for if you are satisfied with the
information click the publish button at
the bottom of the page
five after the chatbot is published you
can find the link to the chat bot on the
Channel's page of the authoring canvas
6. to make the chatbot available on a
specific Channel such as Facebook
Messenger or Microsoft teams you will
need to configure the channel in the
power virtual agents portal and follow
the instructions provided
note that before publishing your chat
bot you should thoroughly test it to
ensure that it is working as intended
and that it provides a good user
experience
you can test your chatbot using the
testbot feature in the authoring canvas
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next topic we'll be covering is
how to make chatbot available in teams
power virtual agents is a no code guided
graphical interface solution that allows
every member of your team to create Rich
conversational chat Bots that easily
integrate with the team's platform
all content authored empowered virtual
agents renders naturally in teams
I.T administrators business analysts
domain Specialists and skilled app
developers can design develop and
publish intelligent virtual agents for
teams without having to set up a
development environment they can create
a web service or directly register with
the bot framework
to make your chatbot available in teams
through the power virtual agents portal
you must perform the following process
steps
why didn't publish the latest bot
content after creating a chatbot in the
power of virtual agents portal you must
publish your Bot before teams users can
interact with it
two configure the team's Channel after
publishing your Bot at the team's
channel to make the bot available to
teams users
three generate an app ID for your
chatbot after adding the team's channel
to your chatbot an app ID is generated
in the dialog box
the app ID is a unique Microsoft
generated identifier for your Bot save
the app ID to create an app package for
teens
Additionally you can add your Bot to
teams using developer portal which
requires another set of instructions
that won't be necessary for the exam
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and the next thing we'll be covering is
how to create a topic perform the
following procedure steps
why in the navigation menu select topics
two select new topic
three if the trigger phrases pane does
not automatically appear select it from
the options to make it visible
for provide one or multiple phrases that
will activate the topic in the trigger
phrases section you can specify more
than one trigger phrase for a topic you
can include punctuation in a trigger
phrase but it's best to use short
phrases rather than long sentences
five select details to open the topic
details pane
6. enter a name for your topic and
optionally a display name and
description the bot uses the display
name when it needs to know which topic
the person is asking about the
description is not visible to users and
is intended for explaining the objective
of the topic to yourself and other bot
Developers
also to modify the name of the topic
select its existing name and provide a
new value and the seventh and last thing
you'll need to do is to select save to
add the topic to the topics list
so these are the following steps to
create a topic
[Music]
hey this is Andrew Brown from exam Pro
and we'll be covering the latest
addition to the Power Platform called
Power Pages Microsoft power pages is a
SAS platform that provides a secure and
Enterprise grade environment for
creating and administering modern
external facing business websites
it is a low code platform that can be
used by both low code makers and
professional developers to quickly
design configure and publish websites
that work seamlessly on web browsers and
devices
with power Pages users can create
in-house websites with ease while
ensuring high level security for their
business data
power Pages offers a redesigned design
studio for a seamless visual experience
customizable templates and an integrated
Learning Hub to assist in building
business websites that cater to specific
needs
power pages also allows users to utilize
the same share business data stored in
Microsoft dataverse for building apps
workflows virtual agents reports and
analytics across various Power Platform
components in an organization so that's
a general overview of power pages
[Music]
the next topic we'll be discussing are
the main capabilities of power Pages
power Pages makes it easy for creators
to author content by allowing them to
quickly produce new websites from the
power Pages home page you can choose to
use the default template or select from
industry specific starting templates
Design Studio creators can build
powerful and captivating sites without
the need for coding expertise the
improved Design Studio includes several
workspaces to support various functions
Pages workspace enables creators to
generate design and organize web pages
styling workspace allows users to apply
Styles and themes to their site data
workspace provides the ability to create
and modify Microsoft dataverse tables
utilized in data powered web
applications
set up workspace facilitate site
Administration and management tasks
responsive rendering power pages is
built on bootstrap a front-end framework
that supports the development of
responsive mobile-friendly websites that
can be accessed across multiple form
factors
websites created by power pages will
automatically adjust to different screen
sizes and devices providing a seamless
user experience
Advanced development capabilities for
pro Developers
users can work with Pro developers and
fusion teams to extend the functionality
using visual studio code and the
Microsoft Power Platform CLI to create
powerful business application websites
security and governance
power pages and built security is its
core enabling organizations to securely
provide access to their business data
for both internal and external users
through Power Pages authorization rules
organizations that use power Pages can
choose from various authentication
providers or allow Anonymous access to
site content
power pages is hosted as Azure app
service which has International
Organization for standardization system
and organization controls and payment
card industry data security standards
compliance
Tower Pages supports modern TLS crypto
standards and includes built-in Azure
DDOS protection additionally it provides
Dynamic IP restriction to limit traffic
from malicious sources and secure
configuration driven mechanisms for
admins to address top web security
vulnerabilities such as injection
attacks cross-site request forgery and
server-side request forgery
it supports Edge caching and web
application firewall capabilities which
can be configured to enhance security
further
power Pages provide some helpful tools
for administrators to manage the
administration and life cycle of their
sites and environments
[Music]
the next topic we'll be covering are
power Pages templates when creating a
new power Pages site you have the option
to select the starter layout template to
build your site or choose scenario-based
templates to speed up the process of
creating your site starter layout
templates the starter layout templates
provide building blocks for you to
create custom sites there are multiple
variations of this template each with
different layout images and colors that
can be used as or customized to meet
your needs after school program
registration template the after school
program registration template is
designed to show you the capabilities of
a Registration site to create events and
allow stakeholders to register
schedule meetings with a financial
institution template
the scheduled meetings with a financial
institution template is designed to show
you the capabilities of a scheduling
template this template allows users to
view the availability of financial
institution representatives and schedule
a meeting online
building permit application template
the building permit application template
is meant to showcase the features of a
site for submitting applications
allowing customers to submit their
building permit applications and receive
email notifications regarding the status
of their application
blank page template the blank page
template offers a completely
customizable website creation option
including a header footer at a single
section on the home page it allows users
to build a website tailored to their
specific needs so these are the various
types of power page templates you'll be
able to select based on your business
needs
[Music]
Andrew Brown from exam Pro and we'll be
covering how power Pages can integrate
with other Microsoft Power Platform
components so power Pages provides deep
integration with other Microsoft Power
Platform components dataverse provides a
secure platform for storing and managing
data that can be utilized by both
business applications and power Pages
sites users can take advantage of model
driven app components such as forms
views charts and dashboards to quickly
and easily display dataverse data
powerapps enables users to create no
code low code custom mobile and web apps
to share and collect data and streamline
business processes using power apps to
create an app that uses SharePoint to
store content is a popular way to
quickly build basic internet sites power
pages is ideal for websites focused on
external audiences that require more
secure access to your business
information
power automate provides a simple way to
create automated workflows with power
Pages you can use power automate for
plugins workflows and automated Cloud
flows to extend business logic and
interact with data and events that are
being transferred in and out of
dataverse
power bi allows anyone to access
visually immersive and interactive
insights from business data with power
Pages integrate with power bi to access
components like reports dashboards and
tiles use the embed capability to
surface data that sits outside of
dataverse
power virtual agents enables teams to
easily create and publish AI driven
chatbot experiences these chat Bots can
be easily added to external facing
websites using power Pages for various
business purposes